call this meeting of the house judiciary
committee to order
and we'll begin this morning by
giving the pledge of allegiance and
representative wolper would you lead us
today
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god
indivisible with liberty
mr clerk would you be willing to call
representative gordon here
representative mcqueen is not here
representative sylvia is not here uh
representative walker is here
representative alexander
no representative green
representative naughter representative
merner representative kelly
representative trottier
representative andres
representative marjorie smith
representative birch
representative morgan
representative lorenzo
representative chase
representative kenny
representative langley
representative macbeth
representative page
well just note that we do have several
people who have been excused
because of illness and for other reasons
and because we have a heavy agenda i
know some people have conflicts with
regard to testifying
on bills and serving on other committees
as well
our first item of business today is a
hearing on house bill 1147 relative to
governmental records available upon
request
and it appears that the
prime sponsor of that bill is
representative dolan
would somebody else like to introduce
good morning mr chair members of
committee representative bob green for
hillsboro 37 i'm here to introduce house
bill 1147
an act relative to government
governmental records available upon
request
thank you very much
seeing no questions your testimony is
okay the
we have several people who have signed
up to testify
and the
thank you uh mr chair uh thank you
members of the committee for the record
barrett christina executive director of
the new hampshire school boards
association we are opposed to house bill
1147.
to be clear we're not opposed uh to the
bill because we don't think the
inclusion of curricular materials
reading lists
students survey dates and questions are
not public records indeed we believe
they are public records which is why we
think that this bill is unnecessary um
rsa 914
list what records are are available for
public inspection and the process of
that there's a definition of
governmental records and public records
and rsa 91a 1a i believe it is
so these these materials are already
public records there's no need to carve
out specific types of records that are
public records because they're already
public records
the right to know law applies to all
public bodies towns cities schools
village districts so on and so forth
there's no other provision in the right
to know law that i'm aware of that
carves out specific exceptions for
certain types of public records so i
don't know why schools should be any
different
additionally
we have a provision in rsa 186 colon 11
a paragraph 9 c and that's roman numeral
9 c
and it says this talks about
objectionable course material about
curricular materials and books and
whatnot that's being taught in public
schools
there's a line that says to the extent
practicable a school district shall make
curriculum course materials available to
parents or legal guardians guardians for
review upon request
well this that statute only limits it to
parents or legal guardians the reality
is if anybody were to call a
superintendent and ask to see
curricular materials reading lists
student survey dates and questions
we would provide them anyway even
without this provision necessarily being
in the law
so no one disputes that these are our
public records we already have
provisions in other law that makes them
available to parents
and there's no specific carve out for
other types of public records for any
other type of public body so we think
the bill is unnecessary we'd ask you to
find it in expedient to legislate and i
would be happy to answer any questions
the committee may have
representative walper
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
do you have any idea what prompted this
bill i mean it seems we don't normally
get bills unless there's some kind of uh
i want to say pretty egregious violation
of the law
so do you have any idea any knowledge of
where these
issues regarding these things have been
an issue in our state i do thank you
very much for the question
representative since the quote unquote
anti-discrimination provisions that were
included in house bill 2 last year
alleging that school districts are
teaching things like critical race
theory
and other allegations
about what's being taught in our public
schools we've seen repeated
voluminous expensive timely right to no
law requests across the state to
view curricular materials to review
teacher professional development
materials so on and so forth so
we believe that
this language was probably introduced
as a follow-up to some of the issues
we've seen with the language that was
included in house bill 2 last year
thank you
any other questions
representative
the
education statutes usually
i understand the
consensus is that uh
the two school districts also apply to
public charter schools but with this um
with this
proposal which puts a
language into rsa 91a which applies to
public bodies or agencies would a
charter public charter school be a
public body or agency
thank you for the question
representative yes
the definition in rsa 91-a colon 1-8
paragraph 5
public agency means dot dot dot
chartered public schools
and i believe
yeah
also in
paragraph 6d of the same statute any
legislative
any legislative governing body board
commission so on and so forth chartered
public schools so the definition of
chartered public schools included in the
definition of a public body under the
any other questions
yes representative simpson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
i just missed your specific reference to
the rsa
that was explicit about parents and
guardians who are requesting information
certainly it's rsa 186
colon 11
paragraph nine c as in cat and the nine
is a roman numeral nine representative
thank you
seeing them thank you for your time
next person we'll call upon is lori
ortilano
good morning my name is lori ordolano
i'm the vice president of right to know
new hampshire and we are opposed to
hb1147
amending the rsa to list specific school
records as governmental records under
the right to know law
hb 1603 fm is a similar bill that is
going to be heard at 11 15 by this
committee and involves uh
turning rsa 91a into a listed more
format of records
for all the reasons that
director
christina spoke to
i would confirm you know
uh agree with what he's presented to you
the rsa 91a definition of governmental
records encompasses in broad terms the
specific language that has been added
with this bill the broad language
defining records should not be
juxtaposed with a list of specific
school records as called out in this
amendment for curricula reading lists
and student survey data and questions
if the legislature starts adding
specific records rsa 91a could become
pages of listed public documents
while school records are listed in this
amended amendment every other municipal
office could request polluted and in my
little
package i gave you i provided you with
rsa 33a which is the municipal
disposition and retention schedule this
document provides a list of specific
documents and document types to be
maintained for a specific time period
so on the town side there's an rsa for
the disposition of municipal records and
it includes a schedule that consists of
roughly 170 roman numeral records
that are public records and have to be
maintained according to a schedule
relative to school documents rsa 189
colon 29a
delineates record retention and
disposition as it applies to school
boards superintendents teachers and
truant officers and i've attached
that rsa to this package as well
boards are responsible now what is
interesting with this is that it does
not include a
list of records like the municipal side
does so it's interesting at the state
level that there is a list of records
that are to be maintained but at the
school level they leave it up to the
superintendent's office primarily to
determine those list of records and make
it available
and boards are responsible for setting
direct and policy to direct the
superintendent to establish a retention
schedule for all official school records
i don't know how widely it's being done
but in nashua i went and got the
retention schedule
and i attached it here
for you to see what's in here and i
think
it's not a complete list and what it
doesn't include really are the curricula
or more school related materials that
are in the classroom that parents are
governmental records mean any
information created accepted or obtained
by or on behalf of any public body or a
quorum or majority thereof or any public
agency in furtherance of its official
duty without limiting the foregoing the
term governmental records includes any
written communication or other
information
whether in paper electronic or other
physical form received by a quorum or
majority of a public body in the
furtherance of its official function
whether a meeting or outside a meeting
of the body
the term governmental records shall also
include public records so that's a very
broad definition public bodies include
by definition any school district or sau
and all specific exemptions are defined
under rsa 91a to provide the
restrictions that apply to records for
non-disclosure so we think that rsa 91a
should be kept in the broadest possible
terms the language we should be listing
things in here we'll end up with a
pretty unruly document that will
probably never be complete and i think
we should encourage potentially looking
at section 189 colon 29a
at the state level listing the records
that are
public school records like we do for the
uh municipal side the the city side i'm
not certain why one does it and one does
not but i know for sure that i think
what director christina director um
christina explained um
that this is a fallout from
people concerned about
dei and
critical race theory being introduced
into the classroom and they want to see
these curriculums and i don't think
these curriculums are as widely
available as they should be the one
thing in nashua i asked parents where do
you get a curriculum if you want it um
they couldn't tell me that that they
could go to a school and get a
curriculum
you go to the grade level that your
child's in if they're in elementary
school go to the elementary school or
the middle school the high school
one of them said you have to go to the
superintendent's office but the
curricula being approved at our school
board tables sometimes it's approved
without the curriculum being present
because it's quote in the computer so
the parents aren't seeing it because
it's digitally not available in a
meeting so that's creating some stress
so i understand why this is happening
but i think we could add clarity but not
in rsa 91a thank you
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
good morning margaret burns executive
director of the new hampshire municipal
association i will be very brief we are
here in opposition to house bill 1147
for the same reasons explained that the
amendment is unnecessary and these
documents are already covered by the
definition of governmental records in
91a and of course i'm happy to take any
questions
any questions from his burns
and
thank you mr chairman um brian hawkins
representing nea new hampshire today um
and i'll i'll say the same thing as mrs
burns we have the same position
that this is unnecessary
that these
records are widely available and
there's no reason to
to change 91a
we across the hall we'll be having some
policy discussions about
you know these items
in house education
and i'm sure that will be a you know
robust debate over there but
i'll close my testimony there happy to
take any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
the um
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 11
seeing no one will declare the hearing
we
expected
we expected more uh testimony than
we received here today and we're not
scheduled for our next hearing until 9
oh
foreign
we'll call the house judiciary committee
back to order
our next item of business this morning
is a hearing on house bill 1322
modifying the governmental records
exempted from rsa 91
a
and the prime sponsor of this bill is
representative huff and we will call
upon representative huff to provide to
introduce the bill and provide his
testimony
thank you mr chairman and honorable
members of the judiciary committee
nice to see you all today uh my bill
is a fairly
simple bill
uh excuse me i'm just pulling up what i
wanted to make sure i cover here for you
um it's a it's
basically
it's a revision in 91a
and the bill would allow the sharing of
personnel records between agencies so
that governmental personnel who have had
maybe a problem
could not escape to another agency
because the other agency wouldn't know
about it
for law enforcement
um
that's where i thought of it
originally and now it's just it fits for
all of your other places if there's
somebody say for example um that did
something uh
maybe dubious at one uh post
had it in their personnel file currently
if they decide to move on or go to a
different jurisdiction
that doesn't follow with them or it
isn't available for the folks who are
hiring them to consider and that's all
it is it's just to you know give
everybody a an equal opportunity to see
who it is that they're actually hiring
so
and with that i'll take any questions
representative trottier
thank you mr speaker thank you
representative
for taking my question a quick question
are you talking just about personnel
files disciplinary files internal
investigation files
or you mentioned personnel files because
i believe already if a
candidate for a position applies and
signs a waiver
a another agency does have the right to
look at their personnel file
thank you for the for the question um i
would defer that to a a following
speaker i don't know the specifics on
that
any other questions for representative
huff
c9 thank you for your testimony thank
the next speaker will be laurie
artellano
good morning my name is lori ordolano
i'm the vice president of right to know
new hampshire and we are opposed to hb
1322 modifying the government records
exemption under rsa 91a colon 5.
the this amendment allows a public body
to share personnel records with other
governmental agencies or departments for
the purpose of hiring the phrase other
agencies or departments is not defined
and could include state federal or
international agencies
in the event that a personnel file is
not correct
misinformation could be widely
disseminated and correcting that
information may not be possible
in addition we believe the language is
too broad and does not define what type
of personnel records can be disclosed
will job reviews be provided to a hiring
company should performance disagreements
between a supervisor and subordinate be
would available fully released to the
hiring department or agency but the
internal disciplinary records could be
released the partial release of records
for an unjust termination could destroy
a person's ability to obtain employment
this broad language added to a colon 5
section 4 could have an unjust and
detrimental impact on a person's future
employment and that's why we're opposed
to this bill
we just feel it's too broad
the next speaker will be sheriff bill
wright
good morning chair thank you
representatives for allowing me to speak
i'm testifying in favor of this bill um
as a hiring authority um just to give
you a little background uh my name is
bill wright i'm the sheriff elected
sheriff of belmont county i've been a
law enforcement officer now for 24 years
i am in my first term of uh being a
sheriff and i am the hiring authority
for my agency
as it relates to uh hiring
um because of my tenure with the law
enforcement community i've seen good
employees and i've seen bad employees
and i've been involved in background
checks of some of these employees where
um if we had been able to see some of
these uh files before we hired these
people we could have identified them as
not being a a viable or a good candidate
and um and that we could have probably
um
had an opportunity to not not employ
these people and and to uh keep them
within the public trust uh so again i'm
i'm in support in support of this bill
and uh part of that reason is because i
believe that
as a hiring authority i should have
access to these records and then make my
own decision as to whether or not this
candidate is a viable employee or not
we all have at some point worked for a
bad supervisor that may have had it out
for us because of differences but that
that can be documented and that can be
refuted by the employee uh through
documentation and uh it opens the door
for that conversation should i decide to
uh to either hire or not hire that
employee or prospective employee i think
that this is important um
information i have even when it comes to
the disclosures of
any type of settlement that was done
let's face it insurance companies uh do
these settlements it's not the the
entity that employs uh most of the time
and that there's information contained
within a a uh
investigation investigative file that
should be accessible to that uh
you know potential uh hiring authority
to make that determination whether or
i have i'm open for questions should
anybody have any
questions for the sheriff yes
representative trottier
thank you mr chair thank you sheriff
right quick question um on that
so these files that you're talking about
would the former or current employee
okay so when it comes to internal
affairs uh there's formal and informal
um internal affairs files that can be
contained so if we get a generic
complaint about an employee sometimes as
a fax finding
opportunity for us and we'll go ahead
and start looking into the matter
um
an example of that would be a complaint
about
an officer running a red light
at that point we go ahead and start
looking at first off uh a quick
investigation into whether or not the
officer was on duty or the deputy was on
duty whether or not they were in that
generic area we may not open up a true
internal affairs investigation to where
there would be disciplinary cause for
that perhaps they were headed to
a location um or what have you that they
needed to get there as an emergency type
situation but it didn't warrant the blue
lights at that given time so we may not
um necessarily create a we want to
create a document that shows that a
complaint came in and that we did a
cursory investigation but at the same
time it didn't raise to the level of uh
where we're going to discipline a person
and involve the unions and
in that type of process so um would that
be uh there and available well it could
be and it would have um
information contained in there that that
you know it ended at the
cursory investigation portion of it that
it didn't raise to the level of a true
investigation so yes those documents
could be available it would have no
disciplinary process but again if these
started stacking up
it gives us an idea of kind of
what the employee's doing and maybe we
need to look into it further so that
i i have a question and
that's i i when
you're
you're is your concern here employment
with regard to officers or is it
employment with regard to
none and
officers
my concern has to do with the police
side of the the field so i i can only
speak of
law enforcement uh portions in general
because those are predominantly the
people that i hire i do hire uh civilian
staff
on occasion that would be our
dispatchers or our administrative
assistants or clerks
which again we would want to obtain
those records as to any type of
internal affairs type situations in
order to to weigh in or to have some
form of a weight to say
whether these people are a viable
candidates or not whether they have
integrity issues or not things that
might that i might question at that
given time and uh we do uh polygraph a
majority of the employees that are uh
hired by us so that might be catalyst to
questions that we would ask during the
polygraph examination as well uh to to
determine truthfulness uh and in the law
enforcement field we are in light of the
public so uh and then with public
scrutiny on uh our jobs as we are i
think this just helps uh with the
transparency portions in the in building
and if i could just follow up on that
because i am under the impression or my
experiences that
police officers are generally well
vetted before they're hired by anyone
and including the polygraph
on occasion
but
the police departments tend to be very
collegial in terms of sharing
information or that's been my experience
as
uh are you
indicating that there are
other agencies that
wouldn't let you know if there were
problems with an officer before you
attempted to hire them what i can tell
you in today's litigation society is
that a response that we traditionally
get from an agency
that that has a prospective candidate
that we're hiring or potentially hiring
in the um
and they have information but they
cannot share it is typically uh they
were employed here between these days
and there's no there's normally nothing
so you can kind of read between the
lines but that doesn't that does not
again we look for uh qualified
candidates to either qualify that
they're
a prospective employee or disqualifying
them as a as an employee and these types
of records are what help us make that
determination to whether or not we
and to retain these people as employees
yeah one
one other question if i could
the
uh
just to get back to the the lorry issue
issue
the typical lori
list
which has been there in the past which
now
will
be more public
has that been available in the past in
terms of determining whether somebody
does have that trustworthiness issue or
some other blemish on their record that
would
cause you to have concerns with regard
to their employment
if a person was entered on the ees list
we would have access to knowing that
that person was on the list or not and
that can weigh into the factors not
everyone on the ees list is
considered a liar or considered
you know an abusive officer or what have
you so there's criteria that that gets a
person or an officer listed on that list
and then we have to determine what
based on inquiries based you know to why
why they're on the list and there could
be a multitude of factors that that
they're on the list then an employer can
make that decision if they want to hire
okay are there other questions for the
sheriff
yes
good morning sheriff um i have a
question about the um
polygraph part of the interview process
um my understanding is that polygraph
reports don't stand up in court as
evidence correct
as far as a criminal investigation
correct yes criminal criminals um so
what value is a polygraph in the context
of the hiring process it's an
investigative tool that we utilize
because even though that we're not using
it in a in a criminal case manner
this has to do with uh the employment of
a person so people are more apt to tell
us the truth as to what's going on in
to coincide with the information that
we've gone out and physically obtained
or
inquired about so it's a supporting
factor it's another tool how much weight
would you follow up thank you how much
weight do you think a polygraph would um
hold in a in the entire hiring decision
unfortunately it's up to the hiring
authority i i don't um
i really can't answer that i think that
if a person had
shown deception within a polygraph
examination and i'm only speaking on
behalf of myself as a hiring authority
um that would generate more questions
to reinterview this person and and to
kind of dig deeper into what is going on
with this process
cnn thank you for your testimony today
and
thank you very much mr chairman uh for
the record brian hawkins uh nea new
hampshire uh
uh
we we share uh some of the concerns that
described earlier with respect to this
bill
but so i'll i won't repeat those but
i'll add just
first i think there there is a little
bit that is confusing to this in terms
of
you know what is the definition of a
governmental agency so for example if
i'm a teacher and i see a
an interesting job i want to take at the
department of education does it mean
that those two
agencies
if they're included in as agencies
are part of this um but presuming that
they are because we're talking about
uh
91a
i think this is in the wrong place to be
talking about
uh this i think this probably belongs in
our
labor or employment statutes rather than
in 91a
over the last several years the
department
of education state board of education
and the legislature has undergone some
numerous changes to
the the laws to
they are adding uh
provisions to
what's called section five violations
these are violations that if you are
applying
um
to be a teacher and
will have committed
any of these you you cannot be
employable by a school district
in the state of new hampshire so i think
that there are
existing statutes
that deal with those types of issues um
the uh the other the other question i'll
just i'll go back to my example of the
teacher applying for the doe
does does everything in that personnel
file need to be shared with
the other employer
i'm not necessarily that it does if i've
been a teacher for 10 years
or all my evaluations need to be
shared
each each employer has its own
application process
um and it if it were the other way
around you know that includes a criminal
history records check for for schools so
um
and then just to to to reference
something that was brought up earlier by
representative trotter of course if if
an individual
uh consents uh they can have their
personnel
file course um released so i think that
so
i'll close my testimony there and
happy to try and answer any questions i
can
is there if
if i could just uh
inquire the
i read in the paper about teachers who
have engaged in misconduct and
frequently
they've moved from one district to
their bad behavior in the prior
their prior
job
wasn't
made known to the
new organization that hired them
is there some other
solution to that problem because
apparently it
that seems to be a problem on occasion
right
um
so i think
there have that issue has been
looked at at the
by the legislature by the state board
i apologize for not bringing those those
provisions with me but i'd be happy to
provide what what has been done to to to
try and get at that
again i'd go back to
i think some of those are employment
decisions specific to education and i
don't know that it's i don't know that
91a is the place that we are
that would make sense to to to
thank you representative trottier
thank you mr speaker
thank you for taking my question
i know in law enforcement there's the
ee list or the lorry list is there
anything like that for teachers or other
public servants
um
firefighters teachers or ems
so that's
public to the uh
available to the public so so relatively
uh i got two two parts there relatively
recently um
and and this uh this is actually
something i neglected to mention
with the chairs question is uh the state
board of education um
uh had established a code of ethics and
a code of conduct uh that that that
teachers are excuse me that any educator
with a certificate is required to
abide by
um and and also obligated to report on
um if there is a violation of that so so
so so that that is in place and then
there as i said there are there are
provisions within the certification
process
that
i don't know if i i'd say i don't
know as if you could equate it to like
i guess i'd say there's a similar
goal or intent there to do that i'd be
happy to provide the committee with that
representative langley
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question is it standard
procedure that anybody that's hired for
education has a criminal background
check done
representative trottier
thank you mr speaker thank you for
taking my question
just kind of follow up to the last
representative question um is it just a
kernel motor vehicle record or do they
do character checks as they do with
other public servants
it
it is a criminal history records check
and i will confess that i
i am not an expert on what
gets
vetted through that it does include
i believe it does include not just
convictions though it includes
it includes anything that would show up
under that process um
like i said i'm happy to uh
follow up with you on on um what would
be included in that
other questions mr hawkins
seen then thank you for your testimony
good morning again margaret burns with
the new hampshire municipal association
having heard the testimony here this
morning i just have two comments
relative to house bill 1322.
the testimony
focused on this being needed
particularly for the hiring of law
enforcement officers and law enforcement
agencies and i would just point the
committee to legislation that was passed
just last year amending rsa chapter 41
so adding 41 section 9-c
for law enforcement candidate background
checks i don't know if that law
addresses the concerns that have been
raised here this morning but at least in
part it seems just a little bit
redundant
my second comment would be that should a
provision like this pass
it probably does not belong in 91 a
five
the right to know law of course is about
the public's ability to access records
not about the government's ability to
share records among itself or between
different governmental agencies so there
may be a need if a provision like this
needs to be passed there may be a need
to just locate it in an employment
related statute rather than in the right
to know law
and those are my comments happy to take
any questions
seeing them thank you
is there anyone else who'd like to
seeing no one we'll close the hearing on
i have to admit that i did a poor job of
scheduling today this is our next
hearing isn't scheduled till half past
10 i
from from past experience i scheduled
the hearings for uh yesterday and today
on a wider interval because generally
these topics seem to get more
attention but
apparently i
did a bad job but anyway we'll
recess the committee until 10 30 when
we'll hear our next hearing on house
um
nice
okay
we'll call this meeting of the house
judiciary committee back to order
our next item of business today
is a hearing on house bill 1408
requiring the refund of residential
the prime sponsor of that bill is
representative klein knight
and we'll call upon the representative
to introduce the bill and provide us
with her testimony
thank you so much
chairman of the judiciary committee and
members of the committee i
have this lovely honor for a second time
in less than seven days coming before
you
this is um
a well-intended bill uh helped drafted
by
um
housing um defendant lawyers actually
and and we
have seen and i'm not sure you're aware
of this but
um since there is a lack of supply for
housing
we've seen
people that are showing apartments start
to take advantage
of of people applying
and that
looks like
what we're seeing now is that people
tend to not only charge you an
application fee they will charge you to
see the apartment they'll charge you per
person so if you can't afford the
apartment and you have to have a
roommate situation if you want to see it
with your roommates they'll charge you
per roommate and then they'll charge you
on the application fee they'll charge
you per applicant
um so it's like
and then on top of that
there's no standard rate which we would
think that a background check should be
standard across the board it shouldn't
it should be a
i don't know fifty dollars
is
but we're seeing
application fees everywhere from a
hundred to two hundred dollars
and then we're seeing people hold on to
them
for an excessive period amount of time
and what that does is it limits the
ability for a low-income person
that is trying to find a place to live
afford another application fee
to
choose a different apartment so this
what this intends to do
is
really fairly return somebody's money
if they're not going to be given this
apartment so that they can afford to
i'm open to questions
any questions for the representative yes
representative sylvia
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
you refer to landlords as they
and
put out a blanket statement uh i'm
are you suggesting that all landlords
are taking uh these fees and holding
them and such
absolutely not
i have a really good landlord but that
doesn't negate that there's good and bad
people everywhere
on every side of business on every side
of the aisle
and that doesn't mean that we shouldn't
mitigate
things that affect the good people and
and work together on a common issue that
we're seeing that really disparages our
our citizens and prevents them
from
being able
it's not all of them so
how large is the problem and how do you
know how large the problem is
well thank you so much for your question
um it is a pretty large problem because
not
there's
not all landlords
are even in the state i know a lot of
people that have property here
that live in other states so they don't
really have
the meeting and the face-to-face
humanistic value that some of us are
provided my landlord lives in the same
district but i'm lucky
that he votes for me
quite frankly
so i am very blessed but not everybody
has a good landlord
that knows you personally
a lot of people when they're moving from
place to place
they're relying off the whim of a new
person that they may not even know who's
renting to them and they might be
dealing with a
third party there's a lot of
discrepancies aboard
across the board that we're trying to
basically
streamline this
i would love it if everybody had a
landlord like my landlord
and
we're seeing this as a very common
problem as i don't need to mention
you're probably very aware of the
homeless crisis in manchester
and that it is spreading throughout the
state
thank you
any other questions yes representative
horrigan
um we
well
we haven't heard from the two uh i guess
they're not lobbyists they're advocates
sitting behind you and
i don't know exactly what they're going
to say but they're probably
they're probably
not in favor of
refunding the fees
why not just eliminate the fees
altogether so the issue of refunding
them is uh
so the issue of refunding them then
a reason not to go step further and
just ban the fees all together well
thank you for your question uh
representative horgan i don't think with
all due respect i don't think that's
fair to the landlord
there is
a time that they are going to need to
spend doing a background check and
they're going to have to pay for a
background check
and
i just
i'm trying to
see both sides
i am a representative of not just people
other questions for the representative
representative langley
thank you mr chair good morning
representative thank you for taking my
question
yesterday we had multiple people
testifying around here around
section 8 vouchers and housing choice
vouchers
i wondered for that population as they
are looking to rent an apartment
would
hud or the housing authority provide
them these fees or is this money that
they have to come up with out of their
own resources
as i unders thank you so much for that's
a very good question as i understand it
they actually have to come up with these
fees
so
that puts people that are
living from paycheck to paycheck in a
real bind and with again a lack of
housing if you don't have that money
like this
then you can't apply for the next
available
rental property
so again all this does
is give a fair shake to people that are
finding a place to live
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
for the record i'm the same person i was
yesterday elliot berry from new
hampshire legal assistance
and thanks for the opportunity to come
before you again today
i just for those of you who were here
yesterday
just brief reminder actually for those
who weren't the context for this is a
housing market where the median rent for
a two bedroom apartment is
just shy of fifteen hundred dollars
including utilities a vacancy rate below
one percent
and a population of approximately 27 000
people who are paying over half their is
half their income for rent
so that's the backdrop and i just want
to walk through a typical new hampshire
legal assistance client say an income of
sixteen hundred dollars a month uh
social security disability
uh and she's being evicted from her
current department uh because the
landlord wants to rehab the bill the the
unit and raise the rent so she starts
searching for
a unit and because her income is 1600
she needs the most she could possibly
pay for a unit is 800
which out there is you know it's like
looking for gold
um
she probably needs to apply to at least
10 places and probably more to get
that rare apartment and even if she's
only charged 50 dollars
that you know each time that's five
hundred dollars if she's looked at ten
places in a month and she's going to
find that place she has to do more
that's five hundred dollars and then if
she's probably accepted
she's going to have to pay a security
deposit plus first month's rent
for many on fixed income the application
will stop the search mid-month
because they can't pay any more
application fees
which for some will mean a longer period
of homelessness
so what is the application fee for
often it's a credit check
a criminal records check and the
administrative cost of obtaining and
reviewing other data on the on the
tenant
such as references
under hb 1408 the cost of the criminal
record check
or the credit check is does not have to
be refunded out of pocket costs
are kept and again as the sponsor
mentioned that's a fair thing to do
but the administrative cost
is not something that they can hang on
to think about an administrative cost of
of a processing applications is one of
the most fundamental functions of being
a property manager
it's no different than collecting the
rent
posting the rent in the in the tenant
ledger advertising for vacancies or
doing payroll there are all things that
are just inherent in the job of managing
rental property
and
i don't think a tenant should be imposed
a separate charge for each one of those
um
when there are
10 to 15 applicants or more for every
given vacancy
the amount of an application fee that is
over and above
the cost of the the out-of-pocket cost
for the landlord is just pure gravy
and these never get refunded never
having said all that i do think there
are some improvements in the bill that i
if you don't mind i'd like to run
through that i think could make it a
little bit better for
all inval or
actually for landlords truthfully
um if you were to take a a look at line
where it says within 15 days of
submission of the application by
prospective tenant uh a landlord that
requires an application an application
fee shell
i think because i've been told by
landlords um
and i certainly believe them that
sometimes getting the the uh
return on the criminal record check
is takes longer than 15 days that i
think probably you need if you care if
you were to pass the bill you'd want to
extend that to 30 days
um
otherwise there'll be times when
landlords can't comply
um
the
the second thing is on line 17 and this
is really a simple thing
um
it says
17 and sub paragraph a says
inform an applicant
uh in writing
that they've been the applicant's been
denied
uh it probably ought to say inform an
applicant who has been denied that
they've been denied otherwise you'd have
to take the people who are accepted and
tell them they've been
again it's a silly thing it's just a
minor drafting problem
i would also
recommend that if
the landlord pre-discloses
that they're going to charge 35
for for
he has an out-of-pocket cost of 35
for a uh
criminal record check or x dollars for
credit check if he discloses those up
front
and he
and that's all he charges that he
shouldn't have to send any information
back to the tenant to the applicant
afterwards that everything he's charged
up front is a disclosed out-of-pocket
cost and there's no need to get back to
the landlord about that or to the
applicant about it and then my final
change
which may surprise some people i do
think that the remedy
358-a
that's our unfair and deceptive trade
practice the statute
that's a minimum one thousand dollar
penalty and i honestly think that under
the circumstances that's a tad high and
i would cut it instead of referring to
358a
i would simply make it a 500 penalty
and and largely
as a deterrent i'm not saying that
everybody suffers a 500 injury but if
you don't make it significant there's
you know and no one's policing this
stuff so you
you know you want to make some
significant deterrent and
that's all i have to say and i'd be
happy to answer any questions
questions for attorney barry
representative horrigan um
yes i am i'm glad that's glad to see
your proposed changing uh that 540 810
part that seemed
but um
also the how unusual is it under current
practice to mail a
of survey rejection letter to to uh to
applicants i haven't had to
i have been on both sides of it but i
haven't had to uh rent it place out to
anybody or seek a rental apartment
myself since the last millennium so i've
been fortunate so i may be
behind the times but i don't remember
ever getting
or sending a letter to a potential
tenant usually well yeah the letter i
mean i don't think it's common practice
now but the issue if
any tenant fills out an application then
obviously they fill out where
where they are they give an address so
that if they are accepted they can be
contacted
okay
other questions for attorney barry
and i'm more than willing to work with
uh i i know that dave and nick are here
and i i'm more than willing to work with
people on some kind of compromise but i
just think that in the environment that
we're living in
multiple multiple fees
to try to find a single apartment
imposed on often the poorest people
around
is just something we need to deal with
if i could just inquire is there
is there any limit on
the amount that a landlord could charge
for an application not a limit at all
and i'm sorry representative langley you
also asked the question about whether
hud pays for these uh for section 8
applicants they do not they also have to
raise their own uh hud doesn't pay for
thank you thank you for your testimony
thank you
oh sorry representative lorenzo has a
question
thank you mr claire and thank you for
telling my question uh attorney barry so
in some
suggested changes to this bill
an upfront
notice to the applicant that you're
going to charge fees right
all right
yeah let me try to be clear my concept
is and i haven't written this down my
concept is if all you're charging is the
out-of-pocket expenses say of a credit
check and a uh um
if that's all you're charging you
disclose that up front and then you
don't have to send them anything about
why you're not returned
that's the idea i'm tossing around
and then
just to follow up please
and then um
as far as the penalties
um
all right let's just talk about the
we
said this about a 15 to 30 day
the
there'll be there would be a penalty if
the landlord does not send back the
fees in time in a timely manner
i almost think of this as being similar
to a security deposit law you know and
that and what we
the things that we do to return folks
security deposit
there's a time frame um
and
the
list of what was spent should be
itemized
and
i was thinking in terms of maybe triple
damages
if the
landlord does not return the deposit to
the tenant rather than say a flat 500
i'll be grateful for what any whatever
you folks are willing to impose as a
penalty i do
i do agree with you for sure that it is
very akin to the process
uh about security uh the handling of
security deposits
um
the amount i think has to be enough to
motivate people to comply with uh to
comply with the law
and
i'll happy to leave that to
thank you
thank you other questions
sorry i just have one more thank you mr
cheers i thank you
journey barry for taking my question no
um me we as we're reading through this
it occurs to me that peop many of these
people are homeless or eventually will
become homeless
what type of notification would you see
as appropriate for that population and
how would you facilitate yeah i think
the burden would have to be on the
applicant remember when they come right
i'm sorry when the applicant
makes their app come to the office makes
the application
they're going to have to put an address
down i mean the landlords here will tell
me otherwise but i've never seen an
application that doesn't have an address
if the person is homeless presumably
they will either have a po a po box
a homeless shelter as an address or the
address of a relative where they're
where they are regularly uh uh getting
their mail i think that's but not be on
the landlord to figure it out it's what
whatever
the tenant puts down on the on the
address line of the application that's
where the landlord would have to send
whatever he's obligated to send under
the
under the law
thank you
other questions
have one more question i think and that
and
i can see it being a huge pain in the
neck for a landlord to try to calculate
the expenses
and
then
the amount of the deposit and sending a
letter to it to explain and
i was just wondering if there would be
some benefit to setting
a
a standard amount
for example fifty dollars
that that landlords could charge for an
application fee
if but they could charge more than fifty
dollars but if they did then they'd have
to go through this rigmarole but if a
standard for you fifty dollars they
wouldn't have to do that
is
yeah uh up you know it's funny i've
i've thought about this a lot and i
think that that probably a
it's certainly worth thinking about my
my issue is this there are a number of
landlords right now who don't
who don't uh charge applications
and once you establish the maximum
it often becomes
what everybody does
uh but notwithstanding that reservation
i'm certainly willing
to work with anyone who wants to work on
it
thanks for your testimony thank you
representative lorenzo and so we're
talking about
deposits being universal perhaps
so
can a landlord get in trouble if they
charge a deposit
sure if if
if the
discrepancy is based on
the protected classes of the state and
federal housing discrimination laws then
they can get in trouble otherwise it's
i think you're off the hook
yes represent opera uh i thank you mr
chairman just
very quickly are you going to submit
your suggestions for improvement in
writing
i would be very happy to do that i would
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak on this bill
my name is nick norman
i've been before you many times i'm sure
you know me well i represent landlords
as an advocate for landlords across the
state through several associations
as the government affairs chair for
apartment association and leading the
landlord initiative for landlord tenant
law
i can be reached at
five five 603-432-5554 nine i'd be very
happy to
communicate with anybody on questions on
this and my email is simply nicknorman
yahoo.com
so i wanna tell you what my experience
is as a landlord
of several decades
and 48 units and talking with the
landlords across the state
constantly on different landlord tenant
issues
i don't see
what's been portrayed here
i'm not saying it doesn't happen
but
i would say that it must be a very small
percentage of the landlords that are
taking advantage of that
the situation of charging extra
fees in my company what we do is we
charge 35 dollars for the application
fee
which
covers
the cost
of our credit landlord tenant criminal
not quite a criminal report
which is in the neighborhood of 27
plus
an annual fee
so it's a little hard to predict what
the actual cost is
first off
um and
in my company
when we see
multiple people applying first of all
it's not hundreds of people applying
it's not 10 people applying
we show an apartment and we might
show it
uh
four or five or six times in an
afternoon because it is
truly um a difficult market with that
little available so there's a fair
amount of showings
of those maybe two or three people don't
even show up so it's wasted my time to
and of those maybe i get two
applications
that's what i really see
one to two or three maybe three
but often two in this market
applications so it's not like what
you've been portrayed
um
what we do is we tell the people look i
know you're probably applying to many
places so
we will process everything that we can
do
that doesn't charge
a land a
credit report landlord tenant report and
so forth
and then when it comes down to it
if one application is clearly stronger
than another on what we can do by phone
calls to landlord references and
employment and so forth then we'll be
going with that application and charging
that fee and requesting the report but
we won't be charging
yours because it's not going to be as
strong so
you may get all of your money back
but if if we get to a situation where we
can't make a determination on that then
we have to get both
landlord tenant credit reports
and we will have to process that and
they sign a form up front that says we
understand that the application fee
portion of this money is non-refundable
and in our company is 35
by the way you might have noticed that
david klein and i and elliot were
talking prior to the hearing we're very
willing to sit down with elliot which
we've done many times over the years and
work on something that would be a
a good
mutual ground
on this and i can recognize that what
they're speaking of the first person
could be happening
it could easily be happening so it's
probably something that needs to be
addressed
there's three things that are being
confused here
so let's get clear on terms
there's an application fee
there's a security deposit
which is completely separate
and there's earnest money
so what this bill is about is
application fees
and i'm hearing people talk about
security
but that's not what this bill is about
and it's not about earnest money either
in a contract situation earnest money is
money you put down
that secures the contract and proves
that
you know you're uh
you're earnest in putting the deal
together
and you would lose that if you were to
back out
but if you were not accepted you get all
of that back in total
so um be careful as we're drafting this
our experience in my experience and
talking to many many landlords is that
there is a
very large number of tenants that come
and apply that are falsifying their
applications
it happens
every time i put a market
an apartment on the market
every single time
well occasionally i get a great
applicant first off
but um most often they're lying about
their landlord references
and that's something we take a lot of
time and effort to figure out who is the
true landlord
i could tell you so many stories of
people that have falsified landlord
references and then because of the
time and effort that we put into this
and all the screening and the reports
that we get back we find out who the
true landlord is
and it turns out of course that that was
a bad reference or we never get to speak
to the true landlord because
we just can't find it
so
what this bill says
is all those people that are falsifying
their landlord references
falsifying
their application in different ways or
are falsifying their eviction records
and we spend a lot of time and effort to
figure that out those people get their
so we definitely need to change the
and again we're happy to work with
elliot
and i think you've seen us over the
years come through with win-win
situations
um
i've got written testimony excuse me can
can you get it
okay
um i just quickly see if i've covered
everything
so
you know if the bill was passed as it's
written
it has some detrimental effects to the
applicants
that
if
uh
landlords are not going to be reimbursed
for time and effort
they're going to simplify their process
rather than do what i'm doing they're
going to say well okay i'll just get my
credit reports on every single person
and that's going to give me an instant
like number and a thing to look at and
say
i can read them out there that that's
quicker and then other tenants all the
tenants are being charged
so i there's probably more in here
please read through the points
um i'm really happy to take questions
and
hope that that you will be asking me
questions
questions for mr norman
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
norman for taking my question i just
wanted to set the record straight when i
mentioned the security deposit process
as a way to
return the um apartment deposits
that's all i meant i wasn't mixing
apples with oranges there so i just
wanted to let you know that thank you i
understand but but there were times when
people were talking about security but
they were referring to application piece
representative langley did you have a
question
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
norman for taking my question
in your testimony you made reference to
having checked and validated people's
references
is there any recourse for example if you
got
references that lied if for example i
gave you you know i'm renting trying to
rent an apartment from you and i give
representative judy lorenzo as my
former landlord and there was no
connection there whatsoever do you have
any uh recourse in this in your lease
to uh
respond to that tenant or to make some
changes in the rental agreements or
that's an excellent excellent question i
would love to see something in the final
bill about tenants falsifying
applications
there is no recourse there is no remedy
for the landlord there's no
reimbursement
of that there's no criminal charges
there's nothing that happens to a tenant
when they're falsifying landlord
references
and i can tell you that
in my experience maybe
we get three
in the span of renting an apartment
usually what happens is
the people that are falsifying they're
desperate to get something they're there
first
so i have to weed through all of the
time and effort of falsified
applications before i get to the good
one
i had a tenant that told me oh i don't
have any landlord references because
i my most recent place was
an older lady and she passed away
and before that i was with family
and her name was mary but you won't be
able to speak to her she passed away
guess who i spoke to
i spoke to mary
i found mary she didn't sound dead to me
and it was a bad reference
it just happens all the time just this
two weeks ago i had
two two out of three that falsified
landlord references i called
for the the
landlord
and um
they didn't quite know the property
that's not reasonable
um
like when did you buy it oh a year or
two ago no the tax record says it was
like 17 years ago who's the owner oh i
manage it first he was the owner then
he's the manager
then he gave then he called back a day
or two later and said i found the owner
i called that person they weren't the
owner
sing none thanks for your testimony
thank you so much
it would be nice if you could work with
attorney barry i'd be very happy to
you know it's my favorite thing to come
with a win-win situation
working with elliot
good morning uh for the record my name
is brandon lemay and i am testifying in
favor of this bill
and i'm representing rights and
democracy
and
specifically our manchester work group
called the manchester housing alliance
we are resident uh we are a group of
manchester residents who want safe
affordable homes for everybody in the
city
i want to start off by saying
i work with a lot of tenants i go door
to door
i knock doors ask people about their
landlords about you know their process
in finding apartments what the process
should look like
um and also help tenants through some of
the problems they have with their
landlords um i definitely want to say
that out of all the tenants i've talked
to um i haven't found any of nics that
have had any nic normans that have had
any complaints from what it seems he
seems to be like a pretty reputable
landlord
and really the intent of this bill is to
stop i think bad behavior from landlords
who aren't as reputable as him
and just like representative sylvia uh
said um is it sorry did i get your name
right representative okay um
just as he said you know we shouldn't
demonize all landlords
and i want to just push back a little
bit and say that we shouldn't be
demonizing all tenants either you know
there are bad faith actors on both sides
there are tenants who will lie on their
application fees and there are landlords
who are going to collect access fees um
i think this bill be a great way to
counter those two things out and as um
sorry
and as elliott berry said
administrative fees are part of the job
and i want to look at the totality of
what landlording really is
and we as the tenant
will pay the landlord rent every single
month the landlord hopefully gets a
profit
and they also build equity of the
buildings
the tenant gets a place to stay which is
great but i think the fact that profit
is built into it i think that
a reasonable fee for
an application is just part of the
um
so
my biggest regret is i couldn't bring a
tenant with me who has had to
apply to at least a dozen properties um
there was a woman before this committee
yesterday bree whalen
who struggles to find a landlord who can
find section 8 or who would take her
section 8 voucher
and
she pays surprisingly more money for
these low-income houses for an
application fee than i do for the luxury
apartments that i apply for
generally i find that i pay about 25 to
35 dollars
per application fee for an apartment
that i can rent um i'm very fortunate
right now i'm doing pretty well right
now
so i generally rent
higher end apartments
i'm really surprised to find that lower
income tenants are paying higher fees
than what i'm paying
and they are less able to actually pay
those fees
if i could wave a magic wand in reverse
situation i would
but you know when you have an apartment
where 10 20 30 people are applying
and i presume a good portion of them are
paying an application fee at the very
least
and then they get denied and then those
20 30 people have to keep on applying to
you know sometimes over a dozen
apartments i mean
do the math there
so i really want to
have us think here you know the landlord
is profiting off of this which is fine
you know hey it's a free market economy
um gotta i love america for that um but
the tenant is having a tough time being
able to find an apartment and when you
multiply how many apartments that that
low income tenant has to apply to
it becomes cost prohibitive um i know
specifically that woman she's had to
choose between doing laundry and
applying for an apartment because it was
about the same cost and you don't want
to show up for an apartment tour you
know wearing stinky clothes not a good
way to make a good impression
um so yeah i would highly encourage ben
frost and nick norman
to uh sorry about ben frost elliott
berry and nick norman to work together
on this bill and i really hope that we
can get this passed
and sorry if i went a little long there
i will gladly take your questions
not a problem
representative lorenzo
thank you mr claire and
thank you mr lemay um
just have an observation and that is
that with market apartments um when they
have vacancies they negotiate on you
know what the fees are going to be um
they have move-in specials and you know
and there's a whole slate of things that
they do
um
at the lower end of the scale
folks don't have that luxury lane lights
don't have that luxury to be able to do
that and that's why
you pay less when you're looking for a
market unit than
a tenant looking for moderate or low
income housing or loan you know
affordable apartments would pay more
than what you pay
thank you
oh i really appreciate the context thank
you so much
any other questions from mr lemay
see none thank you for your testimony
thank you so much have a good day
last last pink card i have is from david
klein
thank you
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for allowing me to speak my
name is david klein i am a landlord on
the seacoast i am also a retired
attorney
um
because of the question asked by
representative horrigan about not having
application fees i want to point out
that the application fees have a couple
of different purposes
one of which right off the bat is to
screen out people who are not serious
about
renting the apartment but are just going
to submit if it's free an application
and that will really if we had 100
applications for one apartment it's
going to bog down the process trying to
screen out who's serious and who's not
never mind the good and the bad people
the other other obvious is the one that
we talked about it offsets some of the
real costs we as landlords are occurring
for the credit reports the background
checks which even the drafters of the
bills recognize are real costs and
something we should be reimbursed for
and yes tenants lie on these
applications all the time i've had
people write down jobs that they don't
all sorts of things of that nature i
even had one woman who used somebody
else's social security number and name
totally fraudulent in her application
at this point in my life because when i
hit 70 i had to back off from being
fully involved we have hired a
management company they're charging a
whopping big forty nine dollar
application fee of that a minimum of
twenty five dollars is for the out of
pocket costs they're only charging
twenty four dollars for
their time the various overheads
the problem and if you listen to nick
he's charging 35 it's costing him 37 so
he's getting about 8 bucks
and if you look at this bill
particularly line 24 and something that
even elliot has conceded is overly
burdensome they're bringing in the
drafters of the bill the consumer
protection statute rsa 350 358-a
this has a one thousand dollar minimum
damage clause plus attorney's fees
so that for the eight dollars if nick is
late getting this letter out in the 15
days he's subject to a thousand dollar
fine
now this is a civil penalty it's
actually worse
than if you've missed getting out a
security deposit which is just double
damages and it's a lot more money for
the tenant it's even more onerous i
believe
than
if you can somebody would shoplifted and
committed a class b misdemeanor
so i'm happy very happy to hear that
elliot agreed that this is an overly
burdensome one
second of all it's the wording is shall
be imposed it doesn't give the judge any
leeway in the event
someone's sick because of covid
or other
other things that you relate getting
into the post office
so we my objections to the bill is not
the concept of trying to limit down
these fees and i'm perfectly happy to
work with elia my objection is the
penalties are so severe
that that really the bill is hostile
um
and as i said you know contrast is the
security the security deposit law if you
fail to get it back to the tenant it
simply double damages no attorneys fees
nothing else
and you're still allowed to deduct your
costs your actual unpaid rent damages to
the apartment in the security deposit
law
the procedure also in this particular
bill everything's by mail
and one of the things that i have a
problem with that elliot actually
addressed and i agree with him 100
is that if you take only your costs
that seven and a half dollar fee that
nick was talking about the twenty five
dollar fee by management companies
charges up front disclose it
why do we have to go out and mail a
letter why can't we just email
text
the tenant they've been denied
this bill puts an unduly burden on us
and part of the problem from my
perspective is what if the tenant says i
never got it how do i prove i mail a
letter well there's only two ways you go
to go to the post office and get a
certificate of mailing or you go to the
post office
and send the letter out certified mail
email we have proof because you have it
on the email server and the same with
texting on your phone
so that this puts a burden on landlords
to do extra work where you're not
allowing them to even charge for their
time
this should be an easy procedure
and this is where again ellie and i
agree if you take only your costs that's
disclosed up front the tenant knows that
they're not going to get anything back
because you took that 27
then it should be just a quick easy
denial
via email or something that that don't
have to send someone to the post office
and if you think about any time you've
gone to the post office by the time you
drive there drive back and get through
your transaction you've got another hour
in minimum never mind the cost of the
mailing
another problem with the way this bill
is structured is because the fees the
penalties are so great
you're giving the unscrupulous tenant
or applicant the opportunity to go up
and claim i didn't get it and file suit
and hire an attorney after all the
landlord's going to be paying the
attorney's fees all he's going to do is
hit once or twice for a 50 fee
and he's ahead of the game for about a
thousand dollars
we don't want to incentivize people to
commit fraud we don't want to clog the
courts with these cases this is a small
claim dollar amount should stay in small
claims should not have attorneys
and that's why i
want to work with la bring this bill
down to something
that makes sense and making sense could
be simply that the attorney the
landlords can get their actual
out-of-pocket costs and maybe something
like three times minimum wage the state
minimum wage for their time at seven
fifty seven twenty five an hour you're
talking about twenty one twenty two
dollars so it's not a whole lot of money
one of the reasons why i said that is
if you want to make it
a maximum fee we need to index it to
inflation somehow
because you know right now
we all know what's going on in the
inflation world and we don't know where
it's going and how long it will be and i
don't think we want to come back and we
lit
not relitigate but re re-argue this bill
and try and transform it so that's one
of my ideas what to do with it
one of the things i do want you to think
about as the bill is written this bill
is actually very hostile to landlords
with the penalties exceedingly hostile
one of the problems that we're having in
this state
is we have a very severe shortage of
housing that's why we're here why things
like this are happening
we don't want to enact legislation
that's host makes it a more hostile
environment for landlords to develop and
add to that supply so we've got to tone
this bill down
and make it better make it realistic
and if you're hearing from nick and i
as the landlords we're not objecting to
trying to make something reasonable and
not and get rid of the abuse that's been
put in what we're trying to do is make
it so it's palatable to us
yeah you catch the bad landlord maybe we
use a fine like um elliot had suggested
but not not this thing this is this this
in its current form is just terrible
and let us
give us a chance to work together maybe
you have put this out to a sub-committee
to work with us as another alternative
but this bill as written is just too
hard
four landlords and two in it's an
incredibly cumbersome procedure
and it will only push costs up and that
we don't need because it's gonna
eventually get worked back into rents
i appreciate everyone's time listening
to me and certainly mr chairman i'm open
to questions
representative lorenzo
i'm sorry thank you mr chairman and
thank you mr klein for your testimony
and i have to agree with you
that we want this process to be simple
and not honorous um and clear
so i do hope that you do have the chance
to work together on this and if you want
to like loop in or you have any
questions for me as a former landlord i
would certainly be happy to
assist i appreciate that thank you very
much
seeing seeing none i will note that i
anticipate
an executive session on this bill two
weeks from today so that would be your
is there anyone else who'd like to
seeing none we will close the hearing on
our next hearing is on house bill 1603
defining certain school information as
governmental records under the right to
and
we'll call upon the prime sponsor
representative yokela to provide his
thank you mr chairman and thank you
the purpose of this bill
is to clarify
that
there are a number of things that
schools
are that schools are covered by 91a and
that
that they
need to
um
provide the records when requested i've
heard that from from um
people that have been requesting records
of the schools have been um
not been given this given information
and so i asked
a number of reps
of the co-sponsors especially
what things that they have seen in their
um
time either or or or
have been expressed to them from their
constituents that they see that
the
towns are not
maybe reluctant to or are
not really clear that they are covered
under 91a
and
so
after
drafting the bill
there was
i got a call from
the right to know
uh new hampshire people
about how they
we're not a super big fan of
even though that this list
um doesn't limit anything it's actually
things that are already covered
it's just clarifying it by saying you
know
need to be retained
and they
this list is
includes but is not limited to the
things on this list so it's not actually
limiting anything it's just clarifying
it for
the administrators to be able to
more clearly um
realize the type types of things that
and
so
um right to know new hampshire thought
that there would there was a better
place to put
this list for clarifying to schools and
that's the amendment that i just
um passed around
and it puts it in um
the school reports and and retention of
records of schools
instead of directly in 91a and it just
says
essentially the same language that was
originally in the bill but it's just
putting it at a different section and
saying hey if you need to
you need to have a policy
and and keep these public records um
um to be in compliance with 91a
so
um it's just putting it in a different
section of law so that that um
that 91a is not
overly verbose
because
a problem with it be being um you know a
giant list in 91a so i agreed and
drafted this amendment thank you
we haven't seen the amendment
over um
so as as i understand the your testimony
the the things that were listed at least
listed in your
in the bill it's essentially the ex
it is the exact same list
it's just put in a different section of
law right but i guess my question is uh
based on your testimony
uh
and your reference to right to know
that it's
that these things are already covered
under right to know
you're just
expounding on them or making them more
specific right right because um a lot of
the people that fill the re the right to
know requests are not actually lawyers
you know they're not going to send all
of the documents for the entire school
to the lawyer to decide what is and what
is not
covered they're going to be doing that
filtering mostly on their own and then
if they get caught not giving something
then they will go the lawyer and say you
know
after the fact so this will help you
know the layperson understand what is um
covered under the right to know and so
this is putting it in kind of the school
reports
section of law so that they
um will
will uh so because it's covering school
so it makes more sense to put that in
there so thank you
do you have any concern that
by listing it this way it might be to
some extent limiting
in terms of what people might think is
subject to
well
i
in my testimony at the beginning i
i believe that the
um the statement you know the public
record shall be retained for compliance
with 91a includes but is not limited to
you know is
is as clear as i can get it
sing none thank you for your thank you
today
good morning again margaret burns with
the new hampshire municipal association
um we're here in opposition to
house bill 1603 in major part
for the same testimony that i provided
on a different bill this morning so rsa
91a 1a paragraph 3 already defines very
broadly what is a governmental record
and basically any record that exists in
an ascertainable format whether it's
written whether it's recorded
almost everything falls under the
definition of a governmental record so
adding a list of just a few very
specific types of school records to the
definition statute is simply not
necessary to make them governmental
records they already are governmental
records and certainly the reason for the
broad definition is so that we don't
need an endlessly amended long list in
the statute of what qualifies as a
governmental record that would be
inefficient and in some ways would
undermine having a very broad definition
of a governmental record
i'm just of course seeing the amendment
that was presented for the very first
time if the bill would be amended to
simply deal with the retention of
certain records in the school statutes
then nhma would simply have no position
on the bill if it were just to deal with
retention of records under a school
statute if if that's what the amendment
does so that concludes my testimony i'm
happy to take any questions
any questions for ms burns
sing none thank you for your testimony
today
good morning again and good morning
again members of the committee thank you
chairman gordon barrett christine
executive director of the new hampshire
school boards association just as ms
burns spoke nhsba is in opposition to
house bill 1603 for the reasons that i
stated on the bill earlier this morning
by carving out certain types of school
records
and the right to know law that's not
what the right to know law is supposed
to be for it's supposed to cover
all public bodies the municipal uh
records disposition schedule that's not
a right to no law issue that's telling
municipalities how long they have to
maintain certain documents and that's
rsa
33-a
colon 3-a and there are hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of of records
included in that particular statute
that that municipalities have to retain
for a certain
certain uh level of time um i'll get to
the amendment in a second um the uh but
the bill as introduced i'm on page one
lines 19
through 22 there's some student
information in there that they're saying
are public records so long as the
student information is redacted
specifically paragraph six out of
district placement information with
redaction of student identifying
information
i want to know what they what this would
mean by information um if it's you know
money or a bill perhaps i mean that
that's likely going to be a public
record we have to be mindful though that
if a student um is receiving special
education services and has to be put
placed in an out of district placement
either because the child is medically
medically fragile
has perhaps mental or behavioral issues
in a very small school district
people are going to know who that child
is it's going to be identifiable
regardless of whether or not the
student's name is on those records
pair line 21 paragraph 7 complaints and
responses to complaints with redaction
of student identifying information
nhsba is going to take the position that
that complaint is a student record
is defined under the family educational
privacy rights act federal law ferpa you
may be familiar with that that
the federal law prohibits disclosure of
student records absent parental consent
so a state statute cannot dictate that a
a a complaint from a parent to a school
district even if the information is
redacted it would still be covered under
ferp would be a would be a
student record which federal law
prohibits disclosure of
looking at the amendment
indeed there is no corresponding records
retention statute for school districts
the way there is for municipalities
under rsa 33-a colon 3a
for nhsba we have often borrowed from
that records retention schedule just to
you know to the extent that it may or
may not be applicable or to the extent
that one of the records in that rsa 33-8
colon 3 um is
if there's a corresponding record in the
possession of a school district we
borrow from it um
in terms of records retention
there's a complicated story behind this
i will try to spare you the time
about 15 years ago the department of
education had a records retention
schedule publicly posted on their
website nhsba would keep a copy of that
we would include it as an attachment to
one of our sample policies so when we
would get an inquiry from a school
usually the superintendent as to how
long a particular document would have to
be retained we could point to that and
say this is an nhs this is a new
hampshire department of education
document
the doe redid their website
10 12 years ago and that document was
removed publicly from from public access
on the website at that time i called the
department of education i said is it no
longer on the website because you redid
the website or is the department of
education withdrawing this document as a
as a guide
i was told by the attorney working for
the department at the time we just took
it down because uh because of the
revisions to the website if you still
abide by that old document you will
still be in compliance with the records
retention schedule um i i can access it
but i i want to save everybody's time
it's probably six or eight pages long i
mean it's got everything from federal
grants and income tax records and you
know all sorts of you know federal
documents that are required just you
know based on the federal money that
school districts get some uh you know
workers comp type of documents bond
issues things of that nature it's
massively comprehensive so
looking at looking at the the records
with the revision to this bill
public record and public records which
shall be retained for compliance with
rsa 91a includes but it's not limited to
well
retained for how long because the
records retention schedule previously
proffered by the department of education
at certain time limits on them you know
if this federal grant document has to be
maintained for for 10 years an
employment document has to be maintained
for x number of years our workers comp
file has to be maintained for x number
of years so simply by by by listing
these saying they have to be retained is
that permanently
i just i still don't i still don't get
what this is trying to get at and we
still have the problematic language in
here about the student information
relative to the out of district
placement complaints and responses with
student redaction information so
um we would certainly oppose the bill is
introduced i you know i haven't done a
deep dive into the amendment but just a
quick glance we would certainly oppose
that as well
and i'm happy to answer any questions
that the committee may have
i see none thank you for indulging me
sir thank you for your testimony today
is there anyone else who wishes to
seeing no one
we will close the hearing on house bill
and the committee will be in recess
until one o'clock when we have our next
hearing
gross
oh
well call this meeting of the house
judiciary committee back to order
our first item of business this
afternoon is a hearing on house bill
relative to landowner liability on land
authorized for outdoor recreational
activities
the prime sponsor of this bill is
representative gould
and we'll call upon representative gool
to introduce the bill and provide
testimony
okay
i am our representative linda gould
district 7 hillsborough
and thank you for letting me introduce
hb 1579
as a knowledgeable advocate for rail
trails in new hampshire and their health
recreational environmental and economic
benefits i've identified a
barrier to rails with trails in new
hampshire that this
proposed legislation
can
remedy where active rail lines exist is
often the corridor
that provides the best connecting link
for our state ride rail trail network
owners of active rail lines are
justifiably concerned
about potential liability
from their shared use of their
right-of-way
this bill seeks to overcome that
potential liability
and the concern
just as legislation in other states has
done
i am offering an amendment to hb 1579
this
liability problem was
brought to my attention by the timbaland
owners association of new hampshire
and
they identified this problem for me and
an amendment is a result of that and you
should have that
so
in conclusion
1579 primarily eliminates for railroad
operators
that
allow a trail adjacent to their tracks
and graces greatly increases our ability
to create a world-class network of rail
trails in new hampshire
for our for our recreational uses and
also for
alternative transportation and i hope
that you focus that this is the goal of
the bill
to
eliminate liability for the railroad
operators that's the real goal of this
bill so please keep that in mind as you
listen to all the testimony thank you
very much
thank you are the questions for
thank you mr claire and thank you
representative crude for taking my
questions
i'm looking through the bill and
personal injury
and
i don't see anything about negligence
here
in this bill
well i think probably uh some rail trail
people will be able to uh i didn't
talk about that to you better than i
thank you okay
any other questions for representative
ghoul
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you mr chair members of the
committee my name is israel piedra i'm a
representative from manchester ward 2.
by way of disclosure i'm also a lawyer
and i practice
representing both plaintiffs and
defendants but
i typically plant us in
personal injury matters when i practice
in that area of law so i have
experience in this area and what this
bill affects
i think the bill is well-intentioned i
think it
is designed to assist you know something
that
i'm in favor of of which is
rail trails
um
but
i think that the bill would also have
very negative consequences
the entire purpose of tort law which is
what this affects is to deter
negligent conduct
the possibility of liability in tort
for landowners and other defendants
creates an incentive for those
landowners to maintain their property in
a safe manner so that people that come
onto that property aren't injured
when you remove that incentive by
removing liability
there no longer is a reason for
landowners to make sure that their land
is safe
and that's what this bill does
the representatives question was well
taken
this bill immunizes negligent conduct
that is the purpose of the bill
without negligence there is no liability
if you're injured on someone's property
that person is not liable unless you can
prove that they were negligent what this
bill does is say
if i go into court and i prove to a jury
that this landowner was negligent and
caused my injuries despite all that
there is no possibility of recovery and
that landowner has immunity
in my opinion that's unacceptable i
think it's contrary to
our
system of justice that's existed for
hundreds of years in our jury system
here in new hampshire that's why i
oppose the bill and i know other
speakers will elaborate on the specifics
of the bill but i just wanted to
register my opposition to it
happy to take any questions thanks
questions for
see none thank you for your testimony
today
good afternoon members of the judiciary
committee that's a good one to say
judiciary committee i appreciate your
time this afternoon for the record uh my
name is representative howard pearl
representing merrimack 26 the towns of
loudoun canterbury northwood
and
the other ones no i'm kidding franklin
ward 3 and bosque
so i'm here today to speak in support of
house bill 1579 and specifically more to
202-158-h brings
these changes in the amendment uh
specifically page one line 13 and the
landowner definition and on page two the
landowner liability limited
in providing services to will will
greatly help this bill
so outdoor recreation is a huge part of
new hampshire's economy
this recreation depends on the
willingness of landowners to open up
their lands and trails
unlike other parts of the country where
either much of the land is either owned
by government or is presumed posted
unless permission is obtained
most new hampshire land owners share
their land with others where the land is
open excuse me for pedestrian traffic
and traditional recreation unless it is
posted
this is just part of our culture
what keeps this culture going is a
landowner's ability to manage the land
to economically justify its ownership
and a favorable regulatory and legal
climate
this includes liability protection
amendment 158h addresses what i would
call a gap in our state's landowner
liability protection law
it will include a person providing
services to the landowner the same duty
of care protections the landowner itself
currently receives
as someone who owns land and provides
services to other outer land owners such
as custom harvesting field mowing i was
surprised to hear of a legal action
occurring against a logging contractor
by an ohrb rider using a state trail on
the parcel where they were cutting
i started thinking of my liability as i
provide services to other landowners
it is legal actions like the one i heard
about that compel landowners to post
their property
it also sends a ripple through the
entire landowner community where they
now evaluate exposures for them or the
contractors doing work on their property
i also agree all people should be held
accountable for their personal actions
and this includes landowners and those
who provide services to them
this accountability is found in rsa 212
34 paragraph five a landowner cannot
willfully intentionally or maliciously
create
or fail to warn against
dangerous situations
excuse me
passing house bill 1579 with amendment
158h will maintain this accountability
and will provide the state's landowners
an assurance that while their land is
open to recreation
they and those working on their behalf
will have the liability protection that
they need
this this is a big thing for many of us
who own land as we
contemplate how much public traffic that
we allow to come on to our properties
and having this uh
this gap in protection is
a real problem for some of us who are
considering providing services to those
other land so i would really encourage
you to take a look at this and
representative walper
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
it's my understanding that
if you are just allowing people to use
your land for recreational purposes you
already have no liability
but that's you already protected under
other
other laws in the state of new hampshire
so the land owner is it's when you are
doing contracted services so my
understanding of the case that i'm aware
of the landowner also has a a logging
operation
where he was moving some trees and the
the accident that occurred which has
caused the incident they didn't sue him
as a landowner they decided to sue him
as a business owner so that they could
avoid this statute that's my
understanding of the situation
yes
so
the protection that we give landowners
which is part of that is the current use
line
and the protections that go with it
to encourage recreation what you're
saying is that landowners need more
protection than that
because sometimes they aren't just using
given their land for recreation they're
doing other
business enterprises
and they all should be protected is that
what you're saying well i'm saying that
uh you know if if someone is doing a an
activity like forest harvesting this
kind of really where this is aimed at
and there's a situation that arises
obviously they can't be negligent in
their actions and from my understanding
of the case that's pending they weren't
but speaking in general as long as
they're not negligent in their actions
then you need the protection as a
business providing services as well as
the landowner or it would really
potentially
cause some of us who do provide services
to consider doing so in the areas of
any other questions
i i guess the
the the only question that represented
google when she was testifying was
saying that this this bill was directed
at
railroads in particular owners of
railroads
but
having read the amendment and having
heard your testimony it appears that
this is directed to
anybody not just railroads would be
using the property
well it would provide protection for
those that are doing services on the
property again
logging in specific is one that i'm
thinking of
so
with regard to
to logging uh so
your your interest as you've expressed
it is with regard to and you with regard
to the example you used as with regard
to logging
but
if somebody were to come on the property
for other purposes like mowing
a piece of property and
they were to engage in negligent
activity while they're on the property
while they're using liability
if they're negligent
again there there's other provisions
that protect that i'm going to actually
have you
i think uh
jason stock would probably be able to
answer this better he's a lot more
in-depth knowledge on this
so i think i'd ask you to reserve that
question and ask him if you wouldn't
mind
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my
question representative um you were
highlighting two specific parts of the
amendment that you wanted to draw our
attention to and i just missed the
second
the second reference you made sure page
one line thirteen which is the landowner
definition and then page two line six
the
landowner liability limited in the
addition of providing services to
so that would offer someone who's
providing services that that same
protection
great thank you you're very welcome
any other questions
thank you representative thank you
i thought i did
oh you just press it once don't hold it
like like a cork mic okay
is it on now
okay thank you
um
good afternoon my name is bill woodbury
and i am the
legislative chair for new hampshire
association for justice i am also a
practicing attorney in laconia new
hampshire
and
we
are opposing this bill this amendment to
the recreational
immunity statutes
for a number of reasons
uh what i do first wish to
to say is that
it is our understanding as the uh mr
chairperson has uh indicated that this
originated as
um a bill that would facilitate the
creation and management of rail trails
or rail rails with trail
and um i am an enormous fan of
rail trails my family and i have logged
hundreds of miles on them the northern
rail trail the winnipesaukee river trail
we've done the ghost train races down
amherst to brookline they are wonderful
recreational opportunities for families
bill would
dramatically expand the definitions
and i think
undermine
on what this
this statute was originally meant to do
the statutes 2 12 34
and
508 14
their purpose
was to
protect landowners with large expanses
of land who open that land to the public
and say
please you know enjoy my land have at it
but i don't necessarily know what's out
there
uh and i'm not going to
be responsible if something were to go
wrong with something that i'd
you know i'm not having control over
whatever
but the case in case law and the case
interpretation
of this of these statutes that has
occurred
uh over the past few years
even more broadly expands the immunities
available
the case co-envy department of
environmental services
essentially stands for the fact that if
one crosses land to get to
an area in that case specifically a body
of water
where two boys drown
if they cross the land to get to that
area to engage in recreational activity
then the landowner is immune
another case with which i have great
familiarity is dalva dalbervi city of
laconia in which
it was decided that the list of
recreational activities in 21234
included not only activities where
people bring their own equipment
but the use of playground equipment
and specifically uh the use of
structures
in the interpretation of the word
structure in in the statute uh it is our
belief that the railroads and the
railroad corridors and utility corridors
are exceedingly well protected already
and that this expansion of the
definition
of the definitions in both statutes uh
is exceedingly broad and
we have had conversations with various
uh members of the rail trail
community
uh who have indicated that you know yes
you know this is
you know not necessarily wedded to this
language because it does
exceed what is necessary for uh rail
trails i'm not speaking for them in any
way right now but just an
acknowledgement from them that this
exceeds
what the real
what the rail people would need
um but
indicating first if the
uh in the um
bill on page on page one under premises
indicating the premises may include but
is not limited to improved and
unimproved lands private ways roads
buildings and structures
such as lands as well as water standing
on or flowing through or adjacent to
those lands
again already protected already
protected under the current under the
statute and are already protected under
the case law interpretations of the
statute but what we fear is that this
broadens
this the um
the this extends the immunity
not just to to rail trail and utility
corridors um which are likely going to
be better maintained monitored but to
anybody who owns land and has any number
of structures buildings on that land so
you know if a if a person decides
they're going to open that land you know
to to kids to play hide and seek in this
three or four old barns on the property
you know this is so they are going to be
protected under the statute
despite the fact that perhaps they're
not monitoring these structures and the
status of their property as would
normally be expected we believe that
this is
in the the um expansions under you know
508 are equally unnecessary unnecessary
and potentially dangerous
immunities breed irresponsibility as it
stands right now the protections are
exceedingly broad
this is unnecessary and unnecessarily
dangerous
with that i would entertain any
questions the committee has
cnn thank you for your testimony thank
you sir
okay
ready okay we are you can proceed okay
thank you
well good good ordin good afternoon
chairman gordon and members of the house
judiciary committee for the record my
name is jason stock i'm the executive
director of the new hampshire timberland
owners association
we represent timberland owners in the
forest products industry
and
i've come here today to in support of
house bill 1579 and also the the
amendment that representative gould had
distributed at the start of her
testimony as well
zero one five eight h
i've provided copy written copies of my
testimony
and also some background information as
well and i've also provided a copy of
testimony that was emailed to me
from weyerhaeuser
expressing their support for the bill as
well
and and the amendment
i want to give a quick just a very quick
overview of the landscape that we're
talking about and kind of why this bill
and in particular this amendment got our
attention
new hampshire's 83 percent forested
second most forested state in the nation
72 privately owned
in
and much of that almost two-thirds of
that is open to pedestrian recreation
and that's based on information in your
packet but also a survey that we have
done of of current use land owners who
open their land up
so there's a lot of a lot of open land
and a lot of things happening on it
recreationally
hunting fishing hiking bird watching and
and as we all know
recreation and outdoor recreation
tourism is certainly a big part of the
state's culture and economy
um
we've
when we look at as timberland owners
there are a couple things that we really
need to to have in place to make
timberland ownership viable we need to
have markets
that enable it to be financially
justifiable
we also need a good regulatory and and
legal framework
under which to own that property
and liability landowner liability is a
part of that particularly if you have a
lot of land that is open
for recreation um
on you know outdoor recreation occurring
on your property
and the duty of care statute of
rsa 220 212 colon 34
we've been what we were watching and
certainly had an interest in the rail
trail bill
the timing was such that
this summer we got
that bill had come out this
obviously in
december
january this summer we
had begun to catch wind of an incident
on a member's property
where the member a suit had been brought
against them
and i'll explain give you the the
details
and
we thought there was a there was a gap
identif we identified a gap in some of
the liability coverage and we thought
this would be an opportunity to try and
plug that gap
here was the situation
landowner owns a piece of land
down in the hopkinton area they have a
trail that crosses their property it
happens to be it's a state trail happens
to be an old railroad bed
um
landowner also has a logging company
they're out there cutting their wood
out there on a saturday they had been
dragging
tops
hemlock tops across the trail
the trail was not gouged he said it was
as if it had been swept if you can think
of a hemlock tree like a pine tree
and while he was out there harvesting on
a saturday two ohrv riders
have an accident right in the in the
vicinity that he was in
he said he hopped off the machine
ran over talked to them
you guys all right do i call 9-1-1 nope
nope no problem they hopped on their
machines and drove off
he said wouldn't you know it a couple
months later in my mail comes a letter
in this case not to me as the landowner
but to me as a logging contractor
saying you're liable for our damages or
bodily injury you failed to put up signs
warning of
that you're out there and he said in in
his comment to me was
you know where does personal
responsibility end and begin
on some of these things he says i have
my land open
he says i'm an ohrv enthusiast
i know that there's activities going on
in the woods he said clearly this trail
had not been
gouged he said it wasn't as if i was
hauling big red oak logs across it and
and gouged it up or had big furrows
across it
and he says i offered assistance
and he says clearly they were capable
enough to hop on their machines and
write off but yet
here it comes a couple months later i
get i get i get a nice certified letter
in the mail
he's in the process now of dealing with
his insurance company trying to settle
this
and he said you know
i'm out there i'm providing us and he
goes in this case i'm as a logging
company i'm cutting my own land
but he says even if it was someone
else's property i'm providing a service
to them a service that enables them to
continue to economically justify owning
this property and keeping this land in
this trail open
and yet
and and yet i'm i'm on the hook
i'm on the hook for this and he said
that just isn't right
we had talked about this rail trail bill
and whether or not there would be an
opportunity
and so today
what you have before you is is our
attempt at a solution to try to
make it clear that if you are out there
providing services on behalf of that
landowner
your and again back to the question of
negligence you can't be out there
and you heard this already before today
there is some responsibility to that
landowner in that operator
i mean in rsa 212 34a roman 5
you can't be willful you can't be you
can't be
i have the language here
malicious willful
so there's a coverage there so the
argument that well this will just kind
of open the floodgates
landowners are totally protected and
immune from anyone bringing a case to
them we would argue no they're not and
we would argue that
there's still that hook there that if
i'm out there and i'm doing something
foolish but right now this particular
owner is going through the process of
having to deal with
attorneys insurance agents etc
for for what he believes is a
a frivolous frivolous case that's been
brought up brought against him
and so that's
that's our
our testimony we would hope you would
look favorably on this
if there's going to be work on the bill
or further
further discussion about it we would
love to be a participant in that
i will tell you this
incident
this was a significant landowner this
incident has gotten the attention of
other landowners
i get questions so what if someone i'm
doing a timber sale someone walks across
my property and a
dead fall falls across on their head am
i now supposed to put signage up around
my timber sale saying tree limbs tree
limbs in the trees that may fall down he
said where does it end and so
this was our attempt to try and address
this
and again i'd be happy to work with the
committee if there's a subcommittee
however you folks operate
and provide some more insight you're
going to hear from some other landowners
today that have recreation occurring on
the property and kind of get their
thoughts and insight so with that i'll
conclude my testimony and be happy to
try to answer any questions
questions
representative otter thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question i'm just trying to simplify
this
so is this correct
a person owns property and out of the
goodness of their heart they let others
go on to their property to use a rail
trail or whatever and then if the person
gets hurt on this private property this
amendment will keep them will stop them
from being able to sue them
yes and no
simply right now landowners if you're
the landowner if you hold that deed or
if you're the lessee that's already in
law
but in this case if you are i'm working
for you on your property providing a
service for you
and that individual gets injured this
would and again and if i'm not negligent
this would afford me the same types of
protections
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question sir um in the um
example that you mentioned about the
over the o b h f whatever
ohb you vehicle
when i spoke to the logger he said they
did they did have some cuts scrapes and
bruises on them he said they did i
offered to call
i offered to help him out
he said
they declined any
any effort they hopped on their machines
and sped off so he did say there were
some scrapes and bruises and that was
his description of how it went down
thank you
oh i thought i'm sorry
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so
as i read this every logger would be uh
protected and every landowner would be
protected when loggers were cutting on
their land
so the so it the what the amendment does
if i'm a logger i'm providing services
to that landowner
i'm not negligent i'm not malicious
landowners are already protected that's
our intent on this
if someone's injured
it's it's how we interpret this language
if i'm providing if i'm that longer and
i'm providing the service
someone's injured
and i'm not i don't fall under that
category
five
i would be our interpretation is i would
be afforded a duty of care that's not to
say someone still can't try to bring a
suit but we believe this will provide an
other questions represented sylvia
you mr chairman thank you for taking my
question
so the case that you're talking about
the incident
the landowner is not being sued his
company is being sued correct
this
protects
the
logger no matter where he is
correct
other questions
i guess i have one question that so
the scenario that you've painted with
regard to
the logger down in the hopkinton area
the
so let's say the logger was
dragging the hemlock across the railroad
right away
and
as you said he was just brushing it but
let's say he left a gouge
in it and the
rv or the snowmobile
hit that gouge went off and somebody was
injured
would this excuse them from liability
i think
i think it would depend on the nature of
the accident the nature of the gouge
again
i think what they would what it would do
is
cause a burden of proof that they were
in fact negligent under that roman
numeral five
and so were they
did they knowingly
you know did they knowingly have a
hazard out there
if if and so that's that's how we in
that's how we interpret this
i'm not a lawyer and i don't pretend to
be one i'm a tree guy
i appreciate it
thank you for your testimony today thank
did that do it here we go
thank you for giving me a few minutes to
address the committee on this bill my
name is roger turgeon i am a governor at
large of the new hampshire association
for justice i am a dover native and
current resident of rochester um i have
been a practicing in uh practicing
attorney handling nothing but personal
injury cases for over 40 years in new
i am also a rail trail
fan
i've ridden hundreds of miles on rail
trails in various states i contribute to
the national rail trails conservancy
i'm a big fan of them
this bill unfortunately goes way beyond
the original intention of making it
easier for rail trails to be put
together
you've already seen the first parts of
the slippery slope that it introduces
which is the lumbermen jumping in and
saying hey
immunize us too
if you look at the statute it also
actually immunizes anybody else who's
doing just about anything
on property let me first clarify i was
really planning on speaking only about
one issue and that is the leasing
exception to what is a charge i'll talk
about that in a moment but i'd like to
clarify a couple things i've heard
in the last few minutes the last speaker
in particular kept saying oh no it
doesn't immunize you if you're negligent
that's not
true the recreational use statute has
always stood for the proposition
that you are immune from being sued for
negligent activity
so long as you're if you're letting
people use your land for free you're not
charging them even if you are negligent
in allowing a defect on the property
that creates a danger and hurts or kills
people
you cannot be suitable you could be sued
but you'll get thrown out you know the
person will get thrown out you can only
lose a case if you acted willfully and
wantonly and i can tell you in the state
of new hampshire
of the thousands and thousands of cases
that are brought that allege negligence
for various things
maybe
one tenth of one percent of them present
facts that would qualify as willful and
wanton it is an extremely difficult
burden for a plaintiff to prove that the
a big concern i have is what we just
heard about lumberjacking contractors
coming on the property the foundation of
recreational use immunities
is to say if you own land and you're
letting people use it out of the
goodness of your heart
not charging them then we're not going
to hold you responsible if that hand
that land has potholes or branches of
trees that are about to fall off as you
pass under or you know a body of water
that you should look out for you know
i'm not going to have to go put fences
around my water and around the quarry
and stuff like that that's all well and
good we support that i sup i've always
supported that i think it's a great idea
one of the problems here is now that you
start saying contractors let's assume
first of all let me suggest it is not a
great idea
for committees like you or for
individuals to be proposing bills to fix
every single perceived frivolous lawsuit
that happens that's what the courts are
for if that case that we just heard
about is as frivolous as it sounds it's
not going to go anywhere that's what we
have insurance for that's not a big deal
nobody's insurance rates are going to go
up nobody's going to go out of business
what if in that case
the the lumbering contractor was not the
owner of the property it's somebody
coming in
making money
being paid to take the lumber off that
property produce it sell it
pay some over to the landowner for the
basic product
they're being paid
why does that person need to be
immunized from acting
reasonably
from not being negligent
so let's assume that they did you you
asked a question um what if they did
leave a gouge what if they know that
there's
hundreds of
of of snow sleds passing through those
trails that weekend and they go out to
do their lumbering
and in lumbering they're dragging things
across the trails left and right knowing
that they're creating all sorts of
hazards they're around a corner and they
don't bother to tell anybody oh by the
way there's logging up ahead
or what if they decide let's put a chain
across here to keep people from coming
into our logging operations and they
don't bother putting flags on the chain
so someone's coming on their ohrv at 50
miles an hour and they get a chain
across the neck because it wasn't
flagged that's negligent almost
certainly not willful and wanton
that would be immunized under this
statue
already
well i'm sorry under the under the uh
under the additions being made to bring
so i'll leave that at that let me talk
about the basic foundation again being
free use
my concern is the lease provision
under
the statute says basically you're not
going to be liable for ordinary
negligence if you don't charge for use
of your land
and then it says well there's all sorts
of things we call charging and not
charging and one of the things that says
is not a charge is if you lease your
land
so let's say i only let's say i own
a six flags operation i own canopy lake
state park i own a park with all sorts
of amusements on it thinks it can be
extremely dangerous if i don't act
prudently and maintain it
right now i'll be liable if i let a car
fly off the rails or something kids get
hurt or maimed or killed i'll i can be
sued i'll be held liable that's my
primary incentive for maintaining it and
keeping it safe
now under this statute it says if i
lease my property even if i lease it for
good money i'm not liable for what
happens on my land anymore
so why don't i set up a non-profit
corporation
that non-profit corporation says its
purpose is to allow children of all ages
including you know
octogenarians and old people like me um
to go out and come play
and i lease it to that i leased my own
property to my own non-profit
corporation
for
as much money as i could possibly have
hoped to make in profit by running the
business but i let the nonprofit
actually run the business
i no longer have to maintain
my roller coasters i don't have to
maintain my bungee jumping stations i
don't have to maintain anything because
i don't have to be worried about being
sued for negligence
even though
the non-profit is paying me as much as i
ever would have made if i did it for a
profit
that is a huge loop loophole that will
eat up
all of turtle as long as the property
has an arguably recreational use i can
set up this lease loophole set up a
non-profit and keep making money to my
heart's content and not have to worry
about spending money on maintenance
unless my lack of maintenance is so bad
that it amounts to willful and wanton
and that's i mean you know until you see
the roller coaster collapsing
that kind of a case is not going to
happen those are my major concerns
recreational use statutes are a slippery
slope to begin with
this amendment
is
showing how slippery it can be
other people started with rail trails
and now others are already jumping on
saying me too me too it needs to stop
i'm open for questions
i note that there are eight more people
who have signed up to speak today all
the remaining speakers have indicated
their intent to support the bill so and
thank you mr chairman and committee
members
for the record my name is tom thompson
from warford new hampshire
i have
submitted a
letter that i would like to read from
the thompson family tree farm
my name is tom thompson owner of the
thompson family tree farm with my wife
sheila we own and manage 2 800 acres of
sustainable forest
2400 acres of that are in orford in
wentworth new hampshire
i have owned forest land for the last 65
years and have been an advocate for
for years for opening and sharing our
forests with the state of new hampshire
as well as the general public
we have over 12 miles of roads that we
allow snowmobiling clubs to use during
the snowmobiling season
each year
we also own we also open our land for
many activities
for foot traffic such as hunting and
fishing
hiking photography bird watching annual
butterfly counts snowshoeing
cross-country skiing along with many
tours that we give each year
i am here today to support house bill
in the addition of the landowner's agent
to
the duty of care
which will add protection to our
landowners and our agents who work on
our property
new hampshire is the second far most
forested state in the united states
and new hampshire has a total of 4.8
million acres of forest land
which is 84 percent of our state's land
base and of the private land owners like
ourselves own 76
of the total forest in new hampshire
as landowners we want to continue to
continue sharing our land
we also want to be sure we are protected
in house bill 1
with the addition of landowner agent
care of duty
law will go a long way in giving us that
peace of mind
all of us who own
our land have seen
the large increase in use of our forest
in the last two years due to covert 19
pandemic
and the last thing we need to worry
about because we open and share our
lands with either our state or the
general public
is one day receiving a certified letter
in the mail notifying us we or our agent
you will or have heard today that this
has already happened to a landowner who
owns the land
but also has a logging business and was
logging on his land and is now being
sued because of two four-wheelers that
had an accident on his property
remember good forest management is only
one of many benefits private forest
landowners provide in our state which
brings into our state's
economy 1.4 billion in the forest
industry and provides 7400
working workers employed in the forest
products industry
which also adds to our tourism and
recreational industries
one example would be snowmobiling which
brings in annually direct and indirect
over 600 million dollars because forest
land owners continue to open and share
our forest lands and trails which we
built for forestry
eighty-four percent of the state's seven
thousand two hundred mile trail systems
are on private forest lands
please help private landowners by
supporting house bill 1579 in addition
to the landowner agent to duty care law
thank you for your time and
consideration and thank you for serving
the state of new hampshire
representative horrigan maybe maybe i've
heard this today but i missed it but
you're
asking to consider
an anecdote about
a landowner there's a logger being sued
because a 2-4 wheeler's accident on this
property you have any more information
about
when or where this happened or
it's down in the southern part
of the state i think there's someone
here that can identify the location of
that
all right thanks
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
i'm trying to get a sense of how big an
issue it is that we're talking about
beyond the case that has been mentioned
and i'm wondering um
you've been doing this a long time
opening your land and personally thank
you for that um but i wonder in that in
that time if you have ever
been approached with a lawsuit by anyone
who's used your land
we haven't
we have avoided that
up to to this point
i will tell you that we have had severe
vandalism
on our property
and i will also point out back in it was
2011 2012
in manchester there was a landowner
who
a hunter went on his land there was a
deer stand there he went up in the deer
stand
uh and fell out of the deer stand and
turned around and sued the land owner
which was a farmer
uh
that
that one
i believe it was thrown out of court or
it never got too far along as as far as
the suit was however the farmer ended up
having to pay ten thousand dollars out
of his pocket to defend himself and
that's what private land owners fear
every single day
and and you know
this there was a gentleman here just a
few minutes ago he mentioned this
slippery slope this slippery slope may
be
maybe in this state that private forest
land owners who own the bulk of the
forest land in this state wake up one
morning and say you know i've had just
about
enough i'm pulling i'm going to post
every single acre that i have and
nobody's going to be using it
i've i've
fought myself not to go down that road
and after that vandalism i i was really
it was six thousand dollars worth of
damage to our property into our
equipment
and i came home and i told my wife that
in in that same day
we were giving a tour to the forestry
students at the university of new
hampshire
when a person that i asked to go open
the gate as i was giving them a tour
just prior to going on to the
land
he came back and said tom he said the
gate is is destroyed
i found two people up there they stole
your tractor and it's stuck in the mud
and i had to give a tour that day
i i was calm i i told the kids i said
you'll be at my house at two o'clock
and if you're not there i'm calling the
state police
but i went home that night and i told my
wife i said you know i really
am tired of this
and i said i think i'm going to pull the
plug in and and we're not going to do
this anymore
and
i've been married to this woman for 55
years and she said tom
get a good night's sleep and let's talk
about it in the morning
and that's so we
we got over that but i can tell you
that
one
certified letter in the mail
indicating that we're being sued
for all that we do to open our land and
share it not only with the general
public but with the state of new
hampshire
which makes millions of dollars off the
backs of of landowners
just in the snowmobiling
we don't get a nickel for that i don't
want a nickel for it
but i don't want to be i don't want to
have that fear of losing my farm that i
started when i was 11 years old bought
my first woodlot
i don't want to lose it i want to be
able to pass it on to my children
thank you
other questions for mr thompson
representative lorenzo
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
thompson for taking my question
um i wanted to ask you about the damage
that from the vandalism that you
suffered was that covered by insurance
no uh what happened was in that
particular case and keep in mind that we
had had uh many
cases of vandalism on our property but
the trick is
you have to catch him in the act
and that's very difficult to do but this
on this day we caught them in the act
they went to court
we
found a judge that finally was serious
about it and they find them each two
thousand dollars
and they and the judge told them
be sure and look over your back because
if one of you fails to pay i'm going
after the other two
one mother uh walked out
made out of check
at the court and her son went in the
any other questions for mr thompson
thank you very much thank you nice to
need to turn on you mike there you go
thank you good afternoon
hi my name is joyce rose
my husband and i live in kentucky
and we own more than 2500 acres
in nine different towns here in new
hampshire
including andover canterbury concord
grantham heineker hopkinton salisbury
warner and webster
some of this land is in the name of
llc's for liability purposes
most of our lots have walking and riding
trails throughout them
and some have rail trails as well
some trails you can find on the map
probably about five miles of those
trails
are on a map somewhere and other trails
are just small but people use them as
well
we love it when people use our land
they hunt they fish they ride their
horses they walk their dogs they
snowmobile they atv utv
jeep bike and we have people camp on our
land
our land is well used by many people we
as a family with our friends do all of
these things as well
we find that most people are extremely
respectful to the land and they
appreciate our offering
we also own a logging company
and we manage properties throughout all
of merrimack county and we do work in
most towns in central new hampshire
considering our own land
and logging we rotate timber harvests
from lot to lot continually
where the growth of the timber the
markets and the weather warrant a cut
we log for the regeneration of the
forest
this is one way that we can make it
economically possible for us to continue
to own and share with others thousands
of acres of land
i am here supporting house bill 1579 as
well as representative gould's amendment
adding the landowner's agent to the duty
of care law
we of all people understand the thrill
of uneven ground
cool shade and loud motors in the woods
on a balmy summer day
the sense of adventure
on on the vast trails of new hampshire
is unbeatable
unbeatable but
the unknown is definitely there
a flat trail at 10 miles an hour for
hundreds of miles
would be pretty boring it would be
nothing to drive up from massachusetts
for
people trail ride for the unrestrained
exploration of uninhabited land
but if it's taken too far to where it
becomes reckless
chaotic or dangerous the only person
liable should be the one seeking the
thrill
there should be
expectations of wilderness on these
trails including bumps turns trees and
rocks and stumps
all that can be navigated safely by a
controlled rider
where it becomes tricky is if a rider is
not in control becomes reckless and has
an accident
in this case they may attempt to lay the
blame elsewhere
for example with a landowner
or a landowner's agent
the landowner has no control over who
uses the trails the ability the
intention
or the condition of the rider
no control over whether the rules are
as a logging company
we are agents of other landowners
without including agents in this
legislation we become very wary of
working anywhere on land where trails
currently the liability of someone
else's reckless actions on one of these
trails is simply too great
where we could lose everything that
we've worked so hard to build
this became clear to us
when logging our own land when a pair of
atv riders had an accident near a point
in the trail where we had dragged some
wood across our trail
although the trail was not ready the atv
riders used this opportunity
to sue our logging company
as the agent of the landowner
rather than the llc who owned the land
this has definitely dampened our
enthusiasm for keeping our land open for
recreation
and it is having us question what our
exposure is when it comes to working on
our own land
and on our client property
we would love to continue to allow our
land to be open to everyone for people
to enjoy and use responsibly and
respectfully
but we do have to weigh the risks
i never wanted to be one of those
landowners that closed our land off
house bill 1579 and the addition of
representative gould's
adding landowner agent to the duty of
care law will reduce the liability for
the landowners like us
and the agents like us to put the
responsibility of the activities on
these trails back on the people
using the trails
thank you for the opportunity to testify
does anyone have any questions
actually i do have
if if you maybe you could answer the
question just to clarify the suit so uh
you're
you're part of the company that's being
sued in that example that was has been
given
and so what what
what what are the plaintiffs in that
suit claiming that
you the
the company did wrong
um
i probably shouldn't discuss
probably should not say
okay that's fine
and
new hampshire trails bureau recreational
trails really
good afternoon
good afternoon my name is craig rendy
i'm the chief of the bureau of trails at
the department of natural and cultural
resources
and that's within the division of parks
and recreation at the state
with me behind me today is director phil
bryce from division of parks and
so
the bureau of trails just has some
background in our testimony administers
and maintains multi-use trails on state
federal
and private lands which includes over a
thousand miles of ohrv
trails off highway recreational vehicles
300 miles of state-owned rail trails and
over seven thousand miles of snowmobile
trails throughout the state
the majority of our statewide trail
system occurs on private lands because
of the generosity of so many land owners
one of the major reasons landowners are
willing to support public access
on their properties is because of the
liability protections landowners have
with the existing duty of care
and limited liability laws
motorized and non-motorized trail use in
new hampshire plays an important part of
our tourism economy contributing over
one billion dollars of direct economic
impact to new hampshire annually
also access to trails is important to
the quality of life of our citizens
we believe it's critical to ensure that
the duty of care law does what it's
intended to do which is support public
access by protecting landowners
we are aware of several recent liability
concerns that are not expressly covered
under the current duty of karen
limitation of action laws under rsa
212 colon 34
and rsa 508 colon 14.
specifically our concerns are related to
the following situations and examples
landowner lease agreements with the
state for trail use
railroad and utility property and
right-of-ways designated for
recreational use
trails located on state lands
and private landowners who also own a
business and allow trail use on their
property
so with that house bill 1579 has written
includes changes to the charge
definition in rsa 212 colon 34 i a
that includes a lease of such land for
said purposes to the state or any
political subdivision thereof shall not
be considered a charge
the bureau of trails has lease
agreements with several large landowners
around the state
to allow recreational trail use on their
properties
we agree with this change to the
definition and as the duty of care
protections will remain available to
those landowners who enter into lease
agreements with the bureau of trails
the house bill also as written includes
several changes to include adding
railroad property railroad right-of-ways
and corridors to which public access is
permitted
we agree with these changes to ensure
that railroad and utility quarters that
are designated for recreational use are
protected by those duty of care laws and
remain open for future use
and then regarding amendments to the
bill uh just as a general housekeeping
measure we suggest modifying the
landowner definition in rsa 212 colon 34
ib
to include the state or any political
subdivision thereof
it's already used in the existing
landowner liability limited statute of
rsa 508 colon 14 this would ensure
consistency between the statutes
and then lastly landowners conducting
activities such as timber harvesting on
their own land are protected under the
current law
however as you heard if the landowner is
conducting those activities through a
separate business they also own
the business is not protected
we also suggest modifying the landowner
definition to include any business owned
in whole or in part by the landowner as
defined in this section
thank you for the opportunity to testify
on the bill
sing then thank you for your testimony
today
is this mike on it is okay
um thank you for listening to me um i'm
dan luker of pretty flaherty um the law
firm here in concord
i have the pleasure of serving as
council to the new hampshire timberland
owners association um
i just wanted to say a couple of things
first these statutes have been in place
for one for 60 plus years another for 45
plus years
and they do
what they should do they reward or
immunize landowners from negligent in
exchange for their leaving all their
hard-earned property open to
the public for recreational uses
with respect to
and we fully support the rail trail
extensions and the addition of the
utilities and the railroads because they
won't
they won't basically open it up unless
you have an express definition that
immunizes them and that's
one of the purposes here and and the
lease to the state has the same effect
with respect to adding the provision of
those providing services
all we are suggesting here is that
you've already the state has already
immunized the landowner
and if the landowner goes out and
mows
mows the field cuts his timber does it
on his own the landowner's immunized
if the landowner hires somebody to do it
that person becomes a landowner's agent
that like that immunization should
extend to the contractor as well
it doesn't matter if the contract is
making some money on it the landowner is
paying the money that he's making that's
really irrelevant it's he's the
landowner's agent
and there should be
no distinction between the two because
he's working for the protected landowner
and
a couple other things
and these are important the term
negligence has been
bandied about here quite a bit
the statutes immunize the landowner
and we submit those working form from
simple negligence
that would be
the sort of duty of care where you have
to go out and you have to meticulously
walk your property make sure there's no
potholes make sure there's no rock sharp
rocks all that
they don't have to do that in exchange
for
opening up their land to the public yeah
that's that's the quid pro quo and that
makes sense that's why they do it
um
this would not extend
um that protection any further other
than to the contractor working for the
landowner and it would only immunize
them
from
sort of carelessness
you know failure to walk the land
failure to inspect all that stuff
that's simple negligence
but it would not in any way alter the
rest of the statute which says if you're
grossly negligent or if you act
unwantedly or maliciously or with an
intentional disregard for others
yes you're liable for that there were a
couple of examples out there that if
that logger that was doing the work had
cut a bunch of ruts in the past
or if he'd strung a chain across without
flags or if he hadn't put any signage up
that signaled people that he was working
in the area
i submit that would be grossly negligent
because in that situation knowing the
circumstances that demonstrates a
deliberate disregard
for the
the health and safety of others
there's a distinction here
and
if you were to take that that situation
where the logger had strung the chain or
the logger had put a bunch of deep ruts
in a snowmobile or got injured
if you went into court
with this amendment and tried to get the
case dismissed
you wouldn't get dismissed
the other side would say no that's gross
negligence you knew what you were doing
and you had a duty to at least
in that situation
respect the safety of others
there's a big difference between simple
negligence which is again inattention or
failure to inspect which every homeowner
or property owner has that's what's
immunizing the statute here we're just
talking about extending
that protection to the person working
for the landowner
because that's the person indirectly
doing the work
and
that's the sole purpose of this
relatively minor amendment it's not it's
not a long slide not a slippery slope
it's just
expanding the
or acknowledging the landowner's
you have any questions
questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
just
for a second
uh we've heard testimony uh already
today that the standard of wanton and
willful or growth what we call gross
negligence which i understand is not a
term that's used in the courts but
is extremely difficult to prove
and hardly ever successful
so doesn't this nearly
grant total immunity to all agents in
all situations where
like my 27 acres are in current use
oh miss mike um
no
what i'm trying to make is a distinction
between one malicious and intentional
conduct which is a very high standard
but you can be grossly negligent if you
demonstrate a reckless disregard for
others
and the example given if you string a
chain across a snowmobile trail or if
you dig a hole
deep in a snowmobile trail and don't put
any guards around it while you're doing
your logging work or if you drag and
drag timber and cause deep ruts
i submit if i were arguing the case that
your honor this is gross negligence this
isn't negligence
because it's a reckless disregard for
others it's not the situation where a
landowner doesn't know about
such
conditions on his property which is the
statutes are aimed to protect
but if you do something that's grossly
negligent you wouldn't get immunized
if if i could just ask a question and
we're running far behind and i don't
want to
this
bill and the amendment
does not change a property owner's
liability
it the
right now the duty of care the immunity
provided the landowners
stays the same as it is
the as i understand it and
the only issue is whether or not we
extend that liability to agents of the
landowner
and
the
and we've given one example so far
of someone who is an agent who has been
sued
and i'm wondering if it isn't
whether i think and this is the question
that perhaps the committee will have to
deal with
do we now give a blanket liability to
every logger
every timber cutter
or
do we address the example that you've
provided today
and as may have already been suggested
in the prior testimony and that is to
a landowner who is in
operating on their own property if not
in their own name in the name of some
other entity and extend that liability
to that other entity
without just giving a blanket liability
to
every logger because not every logger is
as conscientious as those who belong to
the timber owners association
that's a thought um i i think it might
be difficult to fashion uh what
percentage of ownership they need uh the
devils and the details obviously but
i i frankly don't see a distinction
between me hiring my brother to do it
and i'm a part owner of my brother's
company or me hiring a quality logger
from across the way who's going to be
responsible and do it the same way
they're both acting through me
at my behest
to basically maintain my property and i
as a landowner have an immunity and i
don't see why they shouldn't have the
same immunity just as long as they
aren't again it's not total immunity if
they're
out of line and grossly negligent uh
know what they're doing or disregarding
people statute won't help them
thank you
any other questions
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is rob
johnson and i appear before you
representing the new hampshire farm
bureau as a federation's policy director
farm bureau is an organization made up
of just under 2 000 family memberships
farm memberships and another 1 000 or so
there are other types of supporting
members
and
mr chair your the question you just
asked is it hits it right on is we
um
we're in support and i'm speaking to the
amendment
and
just hearing the discussion i think we
understood the amendment to be a little
more narrowly drawn than i think some
have
that
are concerned and when we first heard
about this case that really caught our
attention and found it very chilling
a number of our members provide
a portion of their property for the
statewide trail system and maybe
everybody doesn't understand what that
is but it's basically the state
snowmobile trail system
and it's not a the state doesn't have on
i my family has a trail statewide trail
system on his property and the state
doesn't have a right-of-way the state
doesn't have an easement it's just an
agreement that i have with my local
snowmobile club
for the use of that
that trail and that's the piece that the
the my understanding has always been our
understanding has always been that the
the uh liability coverage that the state
provides covers the trail itself
technically if somebody goes off the
trail doesn't cover it but that's what
we're asking this extended coverage for
the land not in atlanta but the agent on
that porsche on the trail itself that is
part of the statewide trail system i
think mr chin maybe i misunderstood but
that's your question was getting at
um
as has been mentioned earlier you know a
vast majority of the statewide trail
system is on private property and again
i'll repeat the state doesn't have a
right of way it doesn't have an easement
it's just
us as landowners
agreeing to sit working with the clubs
to provide these recreational
opportunities which we want to do
a lot of the discussion today is talked
about logging
well many of our farms are organized
there's limited liability companies in
other and the the
the
paths or the roads that we allow
the public to use on for this trail
system are the roads that we travel with
our tractors our farm equipment our
cattle
and and that's the concern we have is
that with this has there been a loophole
and we really believe that the the state
has an obligation if we're providing the
service of this public recreation to
make sure that
yeah the the the the case pace may be
frivolous may not be going anywhere
but
as you all know you can sue some anybody
for anything and it's just the the time
in the cost of having to defend yourself
and i'll leave it at that mr chair and
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
we do have four more people who wish to
testify on uh they've all asked for uh
short periods of time and
yeah call upon them if they could be as
concise given that we've had lots of
evidence so far
the jason
no you gotta press the button right
there you go sit on now yep great uh
jason sukup i from manchester massar new
hampshire i represent a trail
development organization called
manchester moves we've been around since
2008.
we've been working hard to develop a
comprehensive rail trail network in the
the reason it's important for this group
to hear the work that we've been doing
is because the work that we've been
doing i think spurred this bill
it spurred this bill because we are very
close to having a statewide rail trail
called the granite state rail trail it's
a nearly contiguous 125 mile
recreational rail trail that spans from
lebanon to salem
and right now it's got what we call the
big problem or the big gap between
manchester and concord
and that's where the people live
it's been easy to develop all the rail
trails on the abandoned lines because
they've been abandoned
and so those are developed and so
they're good but they don't go anywhere
other states like new york just
completed their 400 and some mile empire
state rail trail
ohio has a statewide trail
there's a trail that's going up the east
coast the east coast greenway that goes
all the way from
florida to maine
the attraction of these trails is the
connectivity to the extent that they gap
they're not nearly as useful or
attractive or interesting to visit as a
as a tourist destination
we have an opportunity in front of us to
close the gap between manchester and
concord
along the merrimack river from the
manchester mill yard up to concord an
area that's a freight line has been a
freight line for a long time
very rarely used land it runs coal
cement heavy things that do need to run
through there
by the way that's not an area that is
proposed for the capital corridor
commuter line which is going to
terminate in downtown manchester
this area is going to be freight for the
for foreseeable future
that rail line has been sold it's
currently under agreement with csx
railways out of jacksonville florida
they're purchasing it from pan am
railways
that transaction set to close in april
or may of this year
we've been in interest-based dialogue
with csx for over a year during this
entire process
in coordination with mayor joyce craig
in the city of manchester
victoria sheehan the head of the
department of transportation in new
hampshire
we have had the dialogue
and expressed the opportunity that we
have as a state
new hampshire d.o.t will build a rail
with trail they have the capabilities
and the safety standards to do so they
can only do so with the express
permission of the landowner to date pan
am has always said no the reason is
liability
they don't want the liability
concern
csx a national rail operator has done
these things before and they've done
them in other states and they've said
that they would do them here if there
was a law on the books that was
comparable to the neighboring states
like maine and vermont this law sought
to replicate those laws
this didn't originate as a
well
this this originated
because it would protect the railroad
and the laws that are on the books
already protect the land we were told
that early on
but by defining the railroad
specifically in the law as well
that gave them comfort to give us the
ability to complete the trail
they've asked for the law they've said
if if we had the law similar to other
states we could do the same so that's
the opportunity that's what we hope to
see so
if we had this law
i think we would also get a statewide
rail trail within the next few years i
ask you to support this law
thank you for your testimony are there
seeing them thank you for coming today
you have a question
but we do have a question
yeah let's do a real quick one sure are
you are you testifying in support of the
amended version or the original version
or both
um i'm testifying in support of the
original version
only because i'm not as versed on the
amendment
thank you thank you
scott raniere
again we have three
three more cards
scott you've asked for five minutes i'm
going to hold you to that yeah i'll be
brief
you came down from errol so merrill i
had to hear from you today thank you mr
chairman and committee members my name
is
scott rainier
i'm a resident of arrow new hampshire
and i am the regional manager for wagner
forest management a company based in
lime new hampshire that has been
operating for the last 65 years
i'm also a new hampshire licensed
forester
managing land for a variety of clients
wagner forest management
manages
over 150 000 acres of land privately
owned timberland throughout our state
these lands are privately owned but
they're open to the public
for nearly all traditional recreational
uses such as hunting hiking
snowmobile and atv trail riding
and for access to many water resources
working with the new hampshire trails
bureau
and local atv and snowmobile clubs
from towns such as pittsburgh errol
colebrook berlin and gorham we allow
riding on literally hundreds of miles of
trail connecting these towns
and provide support to the economy that
these recreational activities provide
i am in support of house bill 1579 and
the addition of landowner agents to the
duty of care law
managing recreational use and protecting
our landowner clients as well as
ourselves as agents
is becoming very difficult and costly
we have seen an increase year after year
for the past two decades in all forms of
outdoor recreation on our lands
and during the pandemic
private landowners have seen
a dramatic rise in this use
as a result i found myself spending much
more time trying to increase awareness
to the public of our forest management
activities
i have leaned heavily on the
ever-shrinking number of volunteers from
local clubs to help with safety
awareness and posting signs where
appropriate
managing these private lands as working
forest is vital to the economic
sustainability of property ownership in
our state
adding landowner agents such as
foresters
loggers and truckers
to the duty of care law protects
companies such as wagner
who make property ownership viable in
new hampshire and that's i wanted to
just touch upon the kind of link
wagner represents
well we manage 150 000 acres in our
state
mainly for absentee landowners so they
hire us as an agent
to carry out the forest management
activities on their property we then
also contract out to logging companies
and trucking companies to haul those
forest products to the mill
so it is important to
not so much
just include the logging companies as
much as it would be the forest
so
that's why i support house bill 1579.
thank you very much thank you any
questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thanks for coming down today
you asked for five minutes i'm going to
hold you to that too sounds good thank
you uh is the mic on i believe it is it
is okay so my name is garrett mclarty i
come here as a volunteer along with
jason my colleague another volunteer
with manchester moves and as he
mentioned
succinctly the initial
drive behind wanting to get this law in
place
was the completion of the trail and the
significant quarter that is
has a big gap and we want to see that
gap closed
you know in today's litigious society
private land owners and public land
managers must concern themselves with
issues of liability
the fear of a lawsuit is often enough to
prevent private land owners from opening
the land
for recreational use even though they
would like to share their land with the
public
public land
land managers must also deal with the
issue of liability
and private landowners
and managers
may
and have
used
the issue of liability
as a reason to close off public access
to land
i'm also
coming as a private individual
who wants to see
people
and our community as a whole
move towards health i work in the elite
hospitals as a nurse in the emergency
department
and we see over and over
people coming in
because of long-standing health issues
and
though we can address that in a clinical
setting
our goal would be to move towards
getting people outdoors active and
healthy addressing both physical and
mental health
the slippery slope that was mentioned we
have seen
prior to working in the emergency
department i've worked in the outdoor
industry
in youth programs
taking kids outside and we've seen
over the last 15 years
greater and greater restrictions on
where and how we can take people outside
and encourage people to go outside
because of liability
there was an argument made conflating
outdoor recreation
and a roller coaster
in section c it out it defines outdoor
recreation
and though we could spend
all of our time trying to specifically
name each activity i believe the spirit
of the law is clear there
that outdoor recreation
does not is not a roller coaster
and again as somebody else mentioned the
idea of liability
for somebody putting a chain across the
road
again do we want to enumerate every
little piece that they can and can't do
or do we want to have
a law
that in general protects the landowner
recognizing that there may be other
times that we want to
[Music]
hold them liable for activities that
appear to be negligent
i'm not a liar and i don't know the
exact verbiage and case law that has
been asked for there appears to be a
general consensus
for the
uh
support of the law for the
rail trail and i would also ask that we
consider
other uses like the farms and the timber
industry because that is in the same
spirit of the law keeping land open for
the public for recreation
recreational use in a way that promotes
public health community
and allows there not to be a divide
between those who have land and own it
and are able to use it and those who
don't have access to that kind of land
so i i respectfully ask that we
move forward and support
the both the bill original and the
amendment
thank you very much are there any
questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
chet clem
you're
the last card i will try my best please
cut me off if i get close to three
minutes
my name is chuck clem
i'm here to speak in support of hb 1579
as originally submitted i cannot speak
to the amendment having not had the
opportunity to adequately review it
i'm the president of lime properties a
real estate development company based in
west lebanon new hampshire where we are
helping to revitalize our downtown and
building a mixed-use trail and
transit-oriented development at river
park west lebanon
we own and are developing that 38 acre
parcel we have proactively and
voluntarily facilitated publicly
accessible trails
we are one piece of a larger effort and
as mentioned in earlier testimony as a
landowner we appreciate the protections
of the current recreational use statute
but trail networks are often about
connecting pieces of a puzzle and when
critical puzzle pieces won't participate
because of perceived liability
well anyone who's worked hard on a
puzzle only discover a missing piece
knows how frustrating that can be
i'm an environmentalist a hunter and a
fisherman and thusly a river and trail
advocate i'm also a member of our
downtown revitalization committee where
we're working to with a growing
coalition to expand the popular trail
network through downtown west lebanon
this statute as informed by similar laws
elsewhere in neighboring states will
assist in overcoming key barriers
as has been proven
in new hampshire and nationwide trails
are a transformative force for improving
outdoor access for residents and
attracting tourism their mechanisms for
positive change provide alternative
transportation opportunities and are
drivers of economic development and
equitable access to the outdoors
this bill supports the expansion and
connection of these trail corridors in
west lebanon
this past november governor sununu came
to help demolish the dilapidated
remnants of the westboro railyard this
demolition is symbolic of existing chain
of exciting change to come and a
critical step down the path to west
lebanon's economic recovery
building upon that progress that the new
hampshire legislature put in motion
last night we presented the left to the
lebanon city council our action plan for
west suburban revitalization
central to that effort is reconnecting
our community to the river by using
trails trails that will be assisted by
this bill to tie together historic
neighborhoods new development and
recreation areas
it allows the city of lebanon the new
hampshire department of transportation
and the rail operator to reach
collaborative solutions to finally
achieve trail connections that complete
trails that citizens have been
requesting for decades i thank the
bipartisan sponsors of this bill believe
it speaks to the broad support for
expanding trails and access in new
hampshire
and believe that a recreational use
statute allows commerce and recreation
to co-exist and in doing so creates
symbiotic value for new hampshire
communities thank you for your time
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions
seeing none thank you very much
that is the cards i have is there anyone
else who wishes to testify on house bill
okay good afternoon members of the
committee thank you for allowing me to
speak i will be brief um hopefully under
two minutes
um a couple thoughts i just wanted to
share with the community for the record
my name is marissa chase i represent the
new hampshire association for justice
which is a statewide professional
associate trade association of
approximately 400 trial attorneys
and we opposed hb 1579 as introduced and
we absolutely oppose the amendment that
was introduced to us today
i think we all we all support
the
the spirit of what we're trying to
protect i don't think anybody in this
room doesn't but i think there is a
fundamental lack of understanding about
how claims are brought in new hampshire
our existing statutory and
common law framework because how
statutes get interpreted by the courts
is how they are applied to cases brought
before them
under new hampshire law like gross
negligence is in statutes all across our
rsas it has nev our supreme court has
never
interpreted degrees of negligence in the
civil um
in the civil justice system in new
hampshire so there is no such
recognition for what gross negligence
would be right now that chain across
a trail that was mentioned that is
simple negligence right now in practice
i'm happy to talk further about that
another time when i'm not
already so over the amount for the um
that you've allotted for this hearing
i think it's important that everybody
reads the case dolber v city of laconia
that mr woodbury mentioned earlier again
that already covers the concern that
rail trail folks have
and there's a preceding case to that
called cohen c-o-e-n i will send those
to the committee
um
the state already has sovereign immunity
by statute and case law
uh that has largely been extended to
municipalities especially for
recreational use
um to fix one lawsuit that was filed
that i understand we don't know the
details of this would have
limit unlimited unintended consequences
and i would also point out to the
um for that's to the amendment
it also say as drafted in the amendment
anyone who is hired to conduct work on
land would be covered that could be gas
it could be electrical it could be pest
control which deals with chemicals
um
and those
professions are require special
certification of licensure and are
governed by specific standards of care
in other statutes
the last thing i will say is the bill as
um
the original bill house bill 1579 again
no doubt it's well intentioned
um
i didn't hear that i heard that there
were assurances from csx but
i don't see
any assurances made by utilities like
eversource that owns public
right-of-ways
that there are any assurances that if
this bill passed
new trails could be built on those other
entities that are outlined in the
underlying bill so
i'm happy to answer any questions thank
you for letting me speak last minute
any questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you and that concludes our hearing
and we will
move on belatedly
to
house bill 1021
prohibiting regulation of religious land
use based on religious nature of the
assembly or speech taking place on the
and i will call upon the esteemed
representative wolper to provide his
testimony
ah thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
for the record my name is representative
kurt welper i represent stratford
district three
the towns of stratford and new durham
uh i bring this
the intention of this bill
is
okay i'll have to be modulating my voice
now
okay so for the record my name is
representative kurt walper i represent
stratfor district three the townsville
stratford and new
durham and i bring before you this bill
to protect
religious institution and religious
practices
from
abuse of
local
ordinances
particularly land use ordinances
and uh
i'm gonna i'll just tell you two quick
stories
well one may not quite so but anyway so
there was a church it was in durham
and it wanted to expand from the center
of town to outside town
and to make a very long story short the
long stories it took me three and a half
years
to be able to relocate
because of
what i want to call obstruction
by the local
land use boards
so that wasn't that big a deal to me at
that time
but since then i've heard of other
situations uh and more egregious if you
will situations than that and what my
testimony today is going to consist of
one
that has occurred in the town but is
ongoing
so
there's a hound there's a family
that owns a house and they have prayer
meetings at their house
and they're being told that they can't
do that anymore
because
that's it they have like five or six
people come to the house for prayer
meeting and the town
is trying to tell them that they cannot
do that
because they have now
changed the use of their home
from residential to some sort of
commercial
i kid you not
we have seen
i was going to read a different email
than the one i'm looking at now so i'm
not going to read you the actual story
of that but that's the gist of it right
there
uh we have seen other cases
where churches have wanted to relocate
into commercial zones
and required to have excessive amounts
of parking
or other accesses a lot of of things
have been used
to prohibit that kind of
movement
and establishment of new churches and
i'm guessing
because the fact that when a church
takes over a property it becomes
non-taxable so if you move into a
commercial zone you're taking a valuable
piece of property up to tax rolls and so
they don't want you to do it
so we have anti-discrimination law
against religion
but we haven't really got any way of
protecting
the churches themselves and the people
wanting to found them or or whatever
or practice religion in their homes and
so that's what this bill is for
and with that
i'll take you a few questions
questions
my first question is this um are you
referring to the
evangelical church of durham which is
located on dover road um you know like
about half a mile north of route four
uh yes okay good tip
now
just for the uh just for information for
that controversy happened during a
period of time when i was actually
living in the upper valley so um
churches church is thriving in its
location it certainly is
i've got a more philosophical question
which is
and why
should churches get special uh
consideration especially given that they
don't pay taxes you know like somebody
else has to
pick up the slack you know the
commercial enterprises the homeowners
have to pick up the slack for them so
like why there's only two reasons
one is there's a god in heaven that
governs the universe and he deserves
additional respect
and we have religious practice
in our country has been so protected
forever
the other is we're not asking for
special protection
all we're asking is that in this bill
that no additional
restrictions are placed upon them they
are according to what that bill says is
subject to every other standard use for
questions
see none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you mr chair nate grace for the
new hampshire municipal association
we do oppose this bill um and i did
provide written testimony
uh electronically
and i know for future reference to bring
hard copies
um
so as written hb 1021 does not define
religious purposes
um as such it's unclear how exactly this
would apply
um
you know if it's something simple like
uh an organization wants to build a
church mosque synagogue something that's
commonly uh
commonly understood to be a religious
purpose
that's pretty easy to apply
but where you have something like a
religious group where they're
sincere religious belief is ministering
to the poor
and therefore they want to build a soup
kitchen
perhaps on the property that they
already own or perhaps on a different
property does that now qualify as a
religious purpose and therefore fall
under this or would that fall under
normal zoning
i i don't know the answer to that
um the other
sort of unclear
example
was
uh the one brought up by representative
wolper which was
would this
cover uh you know someone who starts
having weekly prayer meetings at their
residential property it appears that is
the purpose
here but at what point does that
transform into a religious use
um that would that would you know if
somebody had to come before a zoning
board
because they wouldn't be before you know
uh planning or zoning board unless they
were going to
build something on that property
presumably
although they might have some sort of
code enforcement issue
um at what point would that would that
qualify so if they're going to add an
addition to their house
and the addition is going to be you know
for their weekly prayer meeting
does that qualify does it have to be
more than once a week
it's just very vague
and that's
really the root of our concern is
we don't know how to apply this because
we don't have a definition for religious
purposes
we
existing law already requires that
there is no preferential treatment for
one religion over another
and what we've seen in zoning cases that
have litigated this is religious
structures
generally have to see the same type of
regulations applied to them as secular
structures
in order for whatever the regulation is
to be upheld so so long as those two
things are happening they should be
treated the same
thank you
any questions
mr grays
see none thank you for your testimony
today thank you
i'll try to keep it to five minutes
i'll try to keep you to five minutes
okay
um alan godek i live in bedford new
hampshire
and i've been a resident of the state
the municipal association that just
opposed this because they didn't
understand
what is classified as a church i would
say property that is owned by the church
i don't think there's any definition
other than that and the church is
recognized as a 501 c 3 corporation
how can they not know that's a church
purpose
um
just
our church was established about 12
years ago
and
we were renting space
after
starting out at the ski hut and in a
store
converting it in on sundays to a worship
service
and then
we're renting space for almost 10 years
but we're gradually getting pushed out
by the owner
because he needed the space
and
we ended up saying we need to get our
own space so we can do things the way we
would like to do them
so we started looking for property
long short
took us about three years to find a
piece of property that would be close to
suitable
we spent fifty thousand dollars
in planning fees and working with the
town of bedford
um
and after we got through the whole
process we looked at it and said
my gosh if we build here
at this price
will never be able to expand
because
the property behind us was unavailable
and we were so close to lot lines it was
a very long thin
piece of property with two
brooks going through it
in any case
while we were having second thoughts
about this
we got an offer from the person who
owned the property across the street
an offer we felt sent by god
instead of under three acres we would
have over nine acres
and the property had a beautiful house
that we could use for we thought
for
worship while we were building a
sanctuary to accommodate a few more
people
our church at that time was uh we had
between 30 and 35 people attending on a
sunday morning
we had more uh overall that were
attending
but there are only 17 members
of this church
anyways we decided to to go ahead with
the project
and we
spoke to the planning board would there
be any problems
now we'd had nine acres plus to
we worked on it um we got approvals
we did this all by church members
and a logger
that
charged us nothing they just took the
lumber
we did all the clean up
this is a member project
everyone in our entire church has worked
on the property
while we were building it
any cases i don't want to interrupt but
you're getting close to your five
minutes right now okay
i'll try to cut to the chase here
in any case we got started we got the
approvals necessary
um
and so we went for our building permit
we had started clearing in december of
and we went for our building permit in
may thinking it'd only take a few days
it took us till the end of august to get
the permit
by then the mission team that we had
lined up to come and do the framing on
the structure
we couldn't dig to do some other things
besides
putting in the parking lot we were able
to dig there but when we wanted to dig
for a new power line
they wouldn't let us do that because
that went under the building permit
they just blocked us on everything
so we couldn't couldn't do all this work
we finally did get the building up
and we did get the power moved
um
and what do we
get for our reward for our work we get a
cease and desist order from the town
saying we can no longer have worship
services
we
started on in march
of 20.
we had the living room which could
easily hold 30 people
all set up for services and the governor
of course gave his edict about it
covered
we couldn't meet
so we couldn't apply for tax exemption
we thought
uh among other things in any case
about may we started meeting we we
started first broadcasting with for our
zoom mem meetings and then we had people
who wanted to come
and actually worship in person and we
started doing that so we had been
worshiping
for
um
about a year and a half
and suddenly we get to cease and desist
well it's no longer safe
we had logging trucks coming in
we had to every week we had to prepare
parking spaces so it would be safe and a
clear path for our members to meet
and all of a sudden the town says it's
not safe
if they didn't want us to meet they
should have done that at the beginning
no one ever said that when we started
the construction of the addition for our
sanctuary that we would not be able to
meet in the church
and they pulled well you don't have a
certificate of occupancy
we had a certificate of occupancy as a
residence and we could hold
meetings there
and the town
originally said
we won't bother you
but then all of a sudden the cease and
desist we're fighting that in the courts
now
if we had to pay for the lawyers
it would be a huge bill
but we're we've been getting a wonderful
uh
bono uh support
but that that's just one other thing i i
could give you other little incidences
um
do i have any time at all
uh well you've done about 10 minutes so
all right then i'll
let me just give you one
um
of course the house had a kitchen
and the kitchen
entered on into a an attached garage
we tore the attached garage down
and built our sanctuary there
well we wanted to use that as an exit
well you can't exit through a commercial
kitchen
we don't have a commercial kitchen
we have a house kitchen
one for burner stove
we're not going to feed an army there
even the new sanctuary is only
rated to hold 50 people
and if we had learned
sooner
and could have been
that's an a3
designation
we could have said we only want 49
and a lot of the the the problem we have
uh wouldn't happen
one other thing this law does not take
into consideration the size of a church
and a church that has 500 people yeah
they'd better have commercial uh access
and all that
but a church that is trying to get that
and
and transitioning just can't afford all
of this baloney
thank you mr godin are there any
questions from mr godac
sing then thank you thank you for your
patience today you waited a long time to
test thank you for your patience
michael tierney
hi mr journey hello thank you for having
me and thank you very much um
to uh the three sponsors who sponsored
this very important bill representative
wahlberg gould and anneke bergen thank
you very much my name is michael tierney
i'm an attorney from contoco new
hampshire i've represented a number of
municipalities and a number of churches
in land use cases but i'm not here
speaking on behalf of any particular
current or former client i'm here
speaking personally on my own behalf as
a resident of new hampshire has seen
what has happened here in new hampshire
and sees what happens in other states as
well
so let me be 100 clear i fully
emphatically
110 percent support hb
um 1021 as written and i ask that the
committee uh support its adoption
land use regulations should be based on
neutral land use criteria such as the
size of a building or maybe the location
the number of occupants or the traffic
impact
it should never be based on the
religious nature or the non-religious
nature the religious purpose or the
non-religious purpose of why people are
gathering or where they're gathering
whether people are meeting for religious
or non-religious purposes is not ever a
basis
for a municipal regulation
nevertheless throughout the state of new
hampshire many towns
regulate land use based on the religious
nature or the non-religious nature of an
assembly
this is clearly unconstitutional
but the
process for obtaining judicial relief is
a long and expensive process not
available to particularly minority
religions or small churches
so let me just tell you a couple
snippets of what i've seen around the
state over the past 10 years about 10
years ago you had this church in
goffstown that wanted to build on a
property where an event center
was allowed
but churches because of the religious
purpose was not allowed
they therefore needed to go through the
variance criteria but the variance
criteria doesn't include a provision for
whether the ordinance is unlawfully
discriminating or unconstitutionally
discriminating between the purpose of an
assembly of being religious or
non-religious
and so the town was stuck in a bind we
had to go through a long process we did
eventually settle that case in federal
court but not until it went through
needless time delay and expense not just
for the church but for the town as well
the town had to spend tens of thousands
of dollars
several years ago you had the
incident over in pembroke next level
church wanted to convert an existing
building into a church in a commercial
district that allowed movie theaters
and other commercial assemblies but not
churches
ironically when next level church was
going to be opening up in that location
they're going to be having their sermons
be telecast from a different location
and people are going to be sitting in a
room that looked remarkably like a movie
theater um and watching the sermon up on
a screen
but because the content of that sermon
was religious
it wasn't allowed in that zoning
district because the pembroke ordinance
prohibited
churches from the commercial district
while allowing movie theaters
again thankfully we were able to after a
period of time get that resolved and the
church is currently operating there
in hanover similar to what happened in
pembroke you have a zoning ordinance
that allows movie theaters
but prohibits churches
it allows movie theaters in the business
district tells churches you have to go
over the residential district and unlike
movie theaters that are permitted as of
right in the residential district you
have to go through a long complicated
process and convince the zoning board
that you fit within the character of the
area however the zoning board may
discretionarily determine the character
of the area
now we heard a couple minutes ago
that the durham church i think was going
on for five or six years
um the the church in hanover right now
is going on almost seven and a half
years in order to get approvals in order
to build the court has already made some
rulings that the discretionary authority
is unlawful unconstitutional
other rulings are currently under appeal
at the new hampshire supreme court and
i'm hoping that it it limits it eight
years it wouldn't go on to nine or ten
years
and that's hundreds of thousands of
dollars in costs to both the church and
the town
in bedford mr godek talked about his
experience there but just to give you
what i see would be fixed by this
particular ordinance that in bedford the
town is interpreting
their ordinances to say that residential
use and religious use are two different
things and that when you have six people
get together in order to have a birthday
party at somebody's residence that's
under one set of safety codes but when
you have six people get together in
order to have a bible study it's under a
different set of safety codes the same
number of people gathering the same
exact room that has had no construction
done to it has two different sets of
safety codes because of the religious
purpose of the gathering
and so the problem is just not limited
to church let me be clear
and i'm going to keep picking on bedford
for a little bit
with all due re respect representative
gould but in bedford they also have this
parking ordinance and the parking
ordinance in bedford has one rule for
movie theaters
you need more if you're a church and you
need even more if you're a mosque
um
bedford is regulating how many
parking spaces you have and saying that
if you do not recognize the divinity of
jesus christ and you're worshiping in a
mosque instead of in a church
you need almost double the number of
parking spaces
frankly that's just ridiculous
in many many states over half the states
this would be
unlawful by state statute
in fact right down our neighbor to the
south massachusetts has this statute
called the dover amendment
that is very similar to the language of
hb 1021
in that it prohibits the regulation of
land use for religious purposes
you can regulate land use based on the
size of a building based on the number
of occupants but not because of the
purpose
being religious and the dover amendment
down in massachusetts has been on the
books for 70 years they've had lots of
success with the dover amendment for the
past 70 years and the language um that
we heard the new hampshire municipal
association
say is ambiguous for religious purposes
that's identical
to the language in many state statutes
including the massachusetts dover
amendment
i also just want to make clear that
religious purposes language is also
identical to the language in new
hampshire rsa 7223
which is the tax exemption statute and
so land use for religious purposes in hb
mirrors land use for religious purposes
in rsa
7223 and what is land use for religious
purposes
we've had 70 years of experience in new
hampshire for the tax exemption we're
just pulling on over to um
the
land use context
and so i just want to be 100 percent
clear this bill does not give
preferential treatment to churches you
can think of this as the movie theater
bill okay if a town is saying that you
need to have four parking spaces for
each seat in a movie theater it needs to
say four parking for
one parking space for every four seats
in a church or in a mosque or in a
synagogue it can't have a different
standard based on the religious nature
or the religious content
there are all sorts of land use
regulations which are narrow objective
and definite whole building code those
can be applied to churches synagogues
mosques what have you on the same way
that they're applied to movie theaters
walmarts or whatever else you just can't
apply a standard differently because of
the religious nature and i see that i'm
going over time so i just have written
submission if i can just pass it around
it'll be super that'd be wonderful
are there any questions for attorney
tierney
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
is there anyone else who'd like to
seeing no one will close the hearing on
house bill 1021
and move on to our next hearing
which is on house bill 1519 defining
religious belief and protecting it from
discrimination
uh
thank you mr chairman
the prime sponsor of house bill 1519 is
representative foster and we'll call
upon representative foster to introduce
the bill and provide his testimony thank
you mr chairman
um
for the record i am
representative william foster from
hillsboro five which is new boston and
mount vernon
and um
house bill 1519 defining religious
belief and protecting it from
discrimination
this bill is the result of discussions
that i had with voters in my district
the initial issue revolved around some
of the voters in my district who are
seeking realistic religious exemptions
from their employer
and there was concern that some of the
companies
were requiring the individuals to answer
long questionnaires and even get
supportive documentation from religious
leaders to justify
their their exemption and they were
curious as to what course the
of action they could take
if their exemption was rejected
so i started looking into the issue and
i found that the state commission on
for human rights fields complaints of
discrimination in our state
um
and within the anti-discrimination
statutes there were many areas where
an individual's creed or
where the word creed or religion was
used and it was protected against
discrimination
um
but with both the the term creed and the
term religion
they their definition revolves around a
formal statement of religious belief um
a confession of faith um
a system of belief
or a set of beliefs based on the
teachings of a spiritual leader
and
this ran contrary in my mind to the
um
to the natural right that it was trying
to that we were trying to protect people
from being discriminated against
the constitution
the definition revolves around a simple
concept
that every individual has a natural and
unalienable right to worship god in
accordance to the dictates of his own
conscience and reason
and the intent of 1519 is to better
align and protect the protections
provided to the actual rights we're
seeking to protect
it does two important things it puts the
definition of religious belief it aligns
it
to a the dictates of an individual's
conscience rather than a formal
statement system or religious authority
and and
um most importantly it also seeks to get
the government out of the religious
approval and disapproval business
and get them focused on whether or not a
person is being discriminated against
so um it defines religious belief as
the spiritual worshipping
as the spiritual worshipping
um in the manner and season most
agreeable to the dictates of an
individual's conscience and then inserts
the religious belief term
throughout the existing
anti-discrimination statutes and the rsa
is defining
the state commission for human rights
and
so
in
in uh in doing that what we're what i'm
basically
trying to accomplish
is um to
get
the government out of stan you know out
of doing the approval or disapproval of
an individual's religious beliefs
and get it more toward is this person
being discriminated against because of
of those beliefs rather than whether or
not the beliefs are legitimate
um i asked the committee to join me in
supporting this legislat this
legislation and passing the bill out of
committee otp
and i'll take questions
are there any questions for
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um
i think i'm trying to
i do um
personally apart from the legislature do
some interfaith work and i'm trying to
understand
where
those who define their religion more
around practices
than beliefs particularly how that would
fit into your
um
to the legislation and the way you have
defined religious belief
uh when i was trying to define this i
was trying to align it to to um
the way our constitution defines
religious freedom
and
one of the things i did change in that i
didn't go directly to that that and just
pull in that definition because the
definition is the worship of god and
there's i tried to make it as
encompassing as i could okay so there's
people that don't believe in a single
god um like perhaps buddhists or there's
people that believe in multiple gods
like hindus and we have populations of
both in our our state and i want
them to have you know that to be
legitimate for them as well you know and
encompass all the different possible
religions and therefore
when i put it into to
reflect that it's um that it's a
spiritual
worshiping okay i would imagine that
that what you're describing would fall
fall under that okay who would fall
under a spiritual worshiping
in the dictates that's most agreeable to
the dictates of that individual's
conscience
and their logic so i i think it would
incorporate that
seeing none thank you for your testimony
representative edwards you've changed
i apologize i i had spoken with
representative edwards before um
there there is i when i did this i went
through all the statute i could find
where it would apply okay
and and it was pointed out to me that
perhaps i missed some and i had
if i've missed any and you and it can be
found i'm more than happy to amend to
that um so if there's there's brand new
legislation
that was recently passed that it might
need to go into i'm very open to that
this is starting to feel like a who wore
it better episode but um so i'm i'm
representative jess edwards representing
auburn chester and sandown
uh when i heard representative foster
was sponsoring this bill i i got pretty
excited about participating in it
as a nation founded by people fleeing
religious
persecution
it's it's fundamental to our nation's
dna to respect religious beliefs
individual religious beliefs and so i
was kind of horrified
during the state of emergency
when
we
prohibited
worship but you could go to home depot
and i don't begrudge people going to
home depot i went to home depot but
barring people from going and practicing
their religion i i thought was deeply
offensive uh to our history and into
what kind of nation we want to be
so i i support this bill it's very
mechanical it's not very sexy because it
just goes kachinka kachinka kachinka
every place that there's uh sort of a
discriminate
listing of protected classes it gets
added
but one thing that got overlooked and i
think does beg for an amendment
is
in hb2 where we passed
the non-discrimination provisions around
education
the teaching of students
that is not in this bill and so
if the committee
is is open to passing this bill
uh i i
i assume
uh it would be relatively
non-controversial if you're open to
passing it to also include the education
section that
found its birth in hb2 in june
so
so that's really it
if there are any questions i'd happy to
take them
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um
i can you flesh that out for me i'm not
really clear which part of hb2 you're
referring to and
um
if you can just go into some detail
about where you would be putting
religious belief in there
thank you um
so
um i i i ended up having to get deep
into the dirt on hb2 so i'm more
familiar with it than most
there was
you may recall a tremendous amount of
debate last spring around divisive
concepts
i think something brilliant happened
somebody realized that the whole
divisive concept approach was asking for
a constitutional challenge
and somebody said okay rather than
pitching it the way we're pitching it
let's let's let's insert it in hb2 to
say that students are should be free
from discrimination
in
their education
so so like for example if
if a teacher
were to provide a worksheet that said
you know something about
x race being ugly and why race being
pretty
you know that sort of thing has happened
in other states
that would be
illegal under our current law
and and so i would just add religious
beliefs to that
segment because
it leverages the same sort of litany of
protected classes that are found in
354-a
so
we when when that got put together it
was meant to be consistent with the the
civil rights section
does that answer your question
okay and if you if you want i i can it's
i've found the hb2 language multiple
times i can i can pull it out and email
it to you
i can't seem to find it in the rsas but
i can find it in hb2 so i don't know if
it's still in process or what but and
then i do have one other comment to make
as a member of the fiscal committee
we've been improving
millions of dollars to help
[Music]
with refugee support
and uh so we're we're bringing in at
least 240 afghanis um
generally um you know 90
95 or more percent are
muslim
and and so i i i i think making sure
that we're a state tolerant and of
religious beliefs and the differences
between religious beliefs would be
another good way of just um
thank you any questions
yes representative horgan
this is just a point of information just
that i've found a lot of the bills we
passed
last year
are reflected if you go through the
browse titles they're reflected if you
look at the whole uh
chapter but the individual
but the index is not as up-to-date so
some of the individual files were
probably physically on the system but
the index that produces the
uh
the menu with all just the individual
titles and click on that seems to be
lagging behind but you can get better
results if you uh
like for example if you look the whole
rsa-54a i believe those would be in
there which is uh one of the
rsas that hb2 event did last year so
that that's that's true representative i
but i i think the education stuff went
over into the education section of the
rsa oh of course yes
thanks
thank you mr chair thank you for
answering my other question i appreciate
that it's helpful
um
do you have any thoughts about that
about language about religious belief
and practice or religious belief or
practice and not just
belief i think that gets to a broader um
encompassing more religions than
christianity and islam
i i i i don't have anything specific to
answer to your question in in general
i would say the point
of
our recognizing different religious
beliefs is to be tolerant and inclusive
so i would
i would appreciate a definition that was
flexible and more broadly applied
but
i'm not a lawyer so i don't know what
trouble you walk into when you use
excessive definitions
thank you i appreciate that
any other questions
thank you representative
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee i don't think i've been in
front of your committee before so i'd
like to introduce myself paula minihan's
senior vice president state government
relations for the new hampshire hospital
association
representing all 26 acute care hospitals
as well as our specialty hospitals i had
written testimony and i will follow up
with written testimony or notes for the
committee but after hearing the
introduction of the bill
my my testimony changed this bill was
confusing to us but
as you can imagine
there are many many many bills this year
related to vaccine related bills and
this is one of them
it was um and the term that the
sponsor used that convinced me that this
is another attempt to try to
be more vague and confusing relative to
exemptions relative to vaccine
requirements has to do with using the
word conscientious or conscious
it's conscientious objection many of the
bills this year some in front of your
committee
coming up
that use that term i just want to be on
the record the hospitals in new
hampshire allow for exemptions they have
mandate requirements for vaccines
they have always allowed for exemptions
for
medical and religious
reasons there is a process
some may see it as onerous
but it is a fair
process that is
done by the human resources department
and is respectful of everyone's beliefs
and and but they need to go through a
process to be fair
so by adding conscientious objection
which we believe this bill tries to do
then it is makes it too vague and i
think representative simpson was getting
right at that question the other um
asking representative edwards i think
it's too vague and um and
and the current statute when it has
creed in there that does if you look at
the definition of creed it's really it's
related to religion so i don't know that
this bill is actually necessary i think
it confuses the issue too much
what does what it did um point out to me
and i am not a lawyer by any means nor
do i really know um
much about the um commission who i mean
i know about the commission on human
rights but that is not my area of
expertise of course um but
it um
what you find by going through all these
statutes is that we don't have a lot of
consistency sometimes we say religion
sometimes we say creed sometimes the
statute says religious creed but to put
religious beliefs in a statute
i believe would cause a lot of confusion
and would would
make it very very very difficult if not
impossible to
continue to have appropriate fair
exemptions
for employees that request those
relative to
in this case
a vaccination requirement um so
with that i um i will
end my testimony we are opposed to this
bill we think it's confusing and
unnecessary and i'm happy to answer any
questions
seeing none thank you
again thank you for your testimony today
you're welcome
is this on
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee thank you so much for the
opportunity to testify today my name is
frank knack i'm the policy director with
the aclu of new hampshire
um we are at this point at least neutral
it was helpful to get more information
from the bill sponsor about the intent
we are still like the previous speaker
confused about the intent of this bill
um and just to kind of go over a few a
few of the issues that that raised flags
for us
most of the laws that this bill is
amending already have protections for
religion or creed in law for example
under our law against discrimination an
employer who adopts a mandatory vaccine
policy
already is required to make efforts to
accommodate employees
whose religious objections
who have religious objections to
becoming vaccinated similarly title vii
of the
federal civil rights act of 64 which
prohibits discrimination based on
religion
an employer is required to provide
employees with the right to request an
exception to the vaccine requirement a
reasonable exception the standard is
reasonable accommodation if there's not
an undue burden
adding to our concern is you know other
ways that this bill if enacted
could be used to harm people
particularly
people seeking reproductive health care
services lgbtq plus people for example
under this bill could an employer take
action against an employee who refuses
on religious grounds to provide or sell
birth control condoms or fulfill a
medical prescription for reproductive
health care it is unclear
further under this bill could employees
be prevented from being able to comply
with non-discrimination laws because
they have an employee who may hold
religious beliefs that they are not
going to be nice or you know not respect
lgbtq plus people again unclear into
this law and so those are questions that
we have serious concerns about we hope
the committee will look into that
thank you are there any questions
yes representative walper
so uh the confusion to which you refer
about
lgbtq or
i forget which else you mentioned
does that not exist already
we have uh protections in law this law
would add confusion to that and so we're
so i'm just i'm trying to understand how
it would add confusion
uh you are adding in in terms and
concepts that are unclear in this i mean
as the last speaker mentioned
there's lack of clarity on what the
intent of this law is trying to do we
have clarity right now under new
hampshire law to protect lgbtq plus
people this would add um uncertainty to
that at a minimum and so we think that
the committee should look into that more
are there any other questions
see none thank you for your testimony
thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
mr chair yep i'm going to ask you to
fill out a pink card when you're done
yes i will turn that in
so i'm not testifying in favor or in
opposition to this but i just wanted to
identify yourself with a record i
apologize michael tierney of kentucky
new hampshire speaking just on my own
behalf personally i'm not testifying in
support or in opposition but i just
wanted to point out to the committee
that the language dictates of his own
conscience comes directly from the new
hampshire constitution part 1 article 5
and it appears to be being added into
the statutory protections of rsa 354 but
the language is already there in the new
hampshire constitution and pursuant to
the supreme court's mack decision unlike
the federal religious protections the
new hampshire state constitution
protects both
worship as well as practice and that's
holding of the mac decision it does
incorporate practice of a non-theistic
religion
thank you thank you for that
clarification that's helpful
any questions for mr tierney oh i'm
sorry
thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1519
seeing no one
will declare the hearing closed on house
we're just going to take a a five minute
recess
and then we'll start our last hearing
everybody
this
degrees
okay
okay we'll call the house judiciary
committee back to order
our next item of business is a hearing
on house bill 1195
this is relative to public comment
periods at public meetings
the bill was sponsored by representative
dolan but i understand that
we have a substitute for him today and
that is representative baldazero
thank you mr chairman i am a co-sponsor
on the bill and for the record
representative al baldassau rockingham
county district five which is
londonderry
i uh the reason i supported the endorses
bill here a hundred percent i'm actually
on another one
on the similar subject
that's in education
for the last five six years in my
district the school board um has
been denying people any public comment
what they've been doing is putting their
public comment on at the end of the
meeting
meaning just like here
when we have legislation coming forward
which is their agenda that they're going
forward with we are we let people come
in and testify and speak against that
legislation
uh either for or against
well in the school board in my district
you have to wait until they already
passed it before you can say anything
before you can address any of the gender
items and a lot of times it's 10 30 11
o'clock at night and the people of the
district are already gone
uh they're home
they if they're waiting there they've
got their kids on their lap and
everything else while they're waiting to
speak on the agenda item that they had
already passed and it does no good
so
i
was more than happy to endorse this with
representative dolan who was on the
council in my committee because at times
there was uh chairman on the council
did the same thing that waited to the
end of the day and then i hear this is
going but to the representatives
throughout the state this is happening
all over the state
and this is a 91a issue we have the
right the people especially parents with
the kids in school have the right to
speak and it should be done in the
beginning before any votes are done on
agenda items
which is same thing as legislation that
we do parents have a right to be part of
it um
and
so this is why why i got involved in it
because i was called in from flew in
from florida
because the parents were aggravated in
my district and asked me to come home
and speak for them
in which i did i went to the school
board and it was like about 10 30 11
o'clock at night i had to be here the
next morning but i stuck it out and
you know and spoke for them
on behalf of them having the opportunity
to speak and i even told the school
board if you will not give the people
the right to speak
we all work for the people okay and they
have every right
to uh re it's basically like a redress
of grievance constitutional issue in my
opinion
to redressing you know their um you know
boards that are elected by the people
so um
tom dolan who is familiar with it also
asked me to read this letter and he he
under the knife today with a heart
attack i mean having a heart operation
uh so he's in our prayer of my prayers
but anyways it says dear representatives
i contact you today to ask that you
support hb 1195. i am the prime sponsor
unfortunately a seriously health
uh issue prevents me from testifying
i've asked representative balducello to
present on my behalf the purpose in
short is clear this bill requires
municipalities conduct a period of
public comment before a public meeting
for example being before board of
selectmen meet and town council meeting
library meetings school board meetings
recreation meetings planning board
meetings etc i call this the right to
speak bill many citizens have been told
that they have no right to speak and are
excluded from testifying before a local
municipal
meeting
this exclusion has frustrated our fellow
citizens as they attempt to engage with
their local government while some
political entities conduct public
comments
several delegates this period
to the end of the meeting this is
nothing more than a cynical attempt to
home in uh the interested
speaker won't wait several hours to say
two or three lines about a local issue
in other words it should be respectfully
held at the start of the meeting
the requirement is to conduct a public
comment period at the beginning of the
meeting for at least 15 minutes unless
there are no additional citizens wishing
to speak
the meeting chair may always extend the
period as they determine appropriate
representative tom dolan
this is a no-brainer because what makes
the people and i've seen it in my own
eyes in my district what makes them mad
and get excited the people because when
you deny them their right to speak out
on an agenda in the school or in a town
issue or or a planning board issue and
you shut them down
and you know these are taxpayers
and they deserve every right to speak
out you know whether it's good or bad
but in the news they make it sound like
they're bad bad people
you know and they want to fight the
system and they're calling them names
and this and that but i watched the
school board
where a parent asked a question i said i
went to the superintendent i went to the
teachers i went to the principal and
nobody has given me an answer yet so now
they go to the board and the board would
not answer them oh we'll answer an email
and they said well that's why i'm here
nobody's answering my emails or or
giving me the answers
so they really treat them bad naturally
the mother gets all excited and mad
because you won't listen to them and
this is causing problems you know
throughout the whole state we have to
fix this and i'm a local control guy
but when local control guy you know
local control breaks down
the legislature we're not we're not a
home rule state we're at dillon state so
the legislator is given the authority to
tell the cities and towns
this is what you know it can be done
what can't be done and we owe it to the
people of new hampshire to fix this once
and for all and i'll take any questions
i do have one one question i think and
that is
it
and you you reference the fact that we
give people opportunity to speak on
on what we're going to be doing here and
i think that's true
the question i have
is
should that
time period at the beginning of the
meeting be relevant should it
should people be given the opportunity
to speak about what's on the agenda
as opposed to just come in and
express any type of gripe that they have
at the beginning of the meeting and take
the time to do that the if it's a school
board or council meeting
they should be able to go in there and
gripe i mean i get calls about trash and
i tell people i don't do trash gotta go
to the council you know or you know an
area in a certain area there they should
be able to go there and address the
council and address the school board um
it's i mean this is a a no-brainer and i
think we would silence a lot of people
into in the state and put them at ease
because now they know
the door's open for them it's not shot
thank you are there other questions
yeah representative langley
thank you mr chair um thank you mr
representative bill cerro for taking my
question i wondered did the school board
have any rational reason
for why they did this
okay any experience that that's that's a
great question
we have um one who is a chair
of the committee and she's the one
that's already
started about five years ago
um and she didn't run for re-election
there but what happened is two board
members resigned so the boards brought
her back on and then you know all of a
sudden now the
the uh public comments are at the end of
the meeting so i asked her why why would
you do that well we're not a um a
meeting for the people we're doing the
people's business
well if the people you're doing the
people's business then
you know you should let them
add to uh or you know question
on certain agenda items and things like
that but she she didn't think and the
superintendent agreed with me uh because
he said you know you're right this is a
public hearing
for the good of the people we owe it to
them but but
the board
voted there to say no and they put it uh
the public comments at the end of the
meeting
thank you
other questions representative lorenzo
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question to representative
balducero you know i'm thinking about um
how
meetings um are conducted and
there's an agenda
and then um there's like questions and
answers at the end um if we put the
questions and answer the questions at
the beginning
mess with the agenda
uh well why would the people show up
then if you're already gonna pass it and
they have no say why even show
why why come to a school board meeting
with tom meeting if they're gonna wait
until at the end after they already
voted on everything to speak
makes no sense to me i'd say just stay
home and say i'm wasting my time may i
follow up
well because i i think that the
officials would be explaining you know
through the agenda they would be
explaining the steps they're taking or
you know whatever whatever they're
working on um
and that would be information for
the citizens
so then they can
give the
um
the council or
all demand their their feedback
no i hear what you're saying but that's
a form of government control that's a
form of shutting down the people and say
we don't care what you say we're going
to pass it then if you want to say
something about it later it's too late
we already passed it okay thank you
that's what that is thank you
other questions
do you have uh uh representative dolan's
uh
you read his letter do we have that you
should all have it i believe he sent it
to the committee but if you don't let me
know and i'll forward his email why
don't you just do that i can just do
that yeah i love when a plane comes
together
any other questions
representative simpson thank you mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um
so i
definitely experienced in our sau having
the public comment period at the
beginning so i i can see the value in
that for sure um
but i'm wondering there are times when
we've had the agenda in town where
we'll try to make public comment um
for a particular issue like at the time
of that issue so that everybody knows
when it's coming up as opposed to having
all the public comment
for for every ish every item on the
agenda right at the beginning like
sometimes it'll be held to the relevant
to before the relevant conversation and
i just wondered if there's
any room in here for
um
flexibility depending on what the town's
needs are
around the agenda i actually like that
you know i mean that you speak up when
the agenda comes up and that you have a
public comment um but
and i've seen it happen with the
chairman in my town now it's pretty good
guy there he's done that before and it
has let people speak so it maybe it'd be
ideal to put cop launch you know i mean
that
to you know to have public comment in
the beginning of agenda but i hate to
see him tie up if you've got a 15 agenda
there and then tie up 20 minutes or 15
minutes each time
before the agenda versus getting it out
in the open right in the beginning
you know it's let's say they meet at
seven by seven fifty seven thirty you're
already moving in you can be done in
your agenda
so i mean i actually i like that way
there but i think that could be a
other questions
thank you thank you have a good day
thank you again uh chairman gordon thank
you again members of the committee for
the record barra christina from the new
hampshire school boards association
we are opposed to house bill 1195.
uh to be clear our opposition is not
about public comments and hsba certainly
recommends to our school boards across
the state that they do provide for a
public comment period at some point
during the meeting
however we also recommend that there are
some parameters
within that public meeting that i'll or
the public comment portion that i'll get
to in a minute i'm looking at the bill
line three all meetings of a public body
open the public i'm reading the
definition of a public body under rsa
91 a 1 a paragraph 6
a
public body means any of the following a
the general court
including executive sessions of
committees
this committee takes public testimony
you do not take public comment this is a
hearing this is not a meeting there are
distinct legal differences between the
two you have a budget hearing under rsa
32 a hearing implies the public has a
right to come and speak
you have public hearings for bond issues
under rsa i think it's 35 if i'm not
mistaken so i just want to be clear that
me having the opportunity to come and
speak here is because it's a hearing not
because it's a meeting if this were to
pass this committee and every other
committee within this building would
have to have a public comment period
before we actually got into the hearings
and started talking about the bills
um the second aspect to that is that you
cannot i'm on line five and six
shall not limit or censor the content of
uh the public com of the public comment
so when we're in a public hearing i'm
only allowed to talk about this bill or
issues that are germane to this bill if
we are not censoring or limiting public
comment i would be able to come in here
and talk about anything that i wanted to
the war in afghanistan
uh
you know
global warming you picked the topic i'd
be able to come in and talk about it
would not be germaine or relevant to the
business of this of this of this uh of
this body
also the other concern nhsba has um on
blind forts is the chairperson may
develop the length of time for both
total time and individual time through
school board governance that's a school
board policy it's not the chairperson
that does that i suppose the board could
delegate that to the board chair but we
do it through a collective policy
other aspects um you know again we
certainly we certainly agree that it's a
best practice to have public comments um
but if we're talking about sort of you
know open-ended and requiring them as
school board maybe holding
um a hearing again which is being held
in public for say an employee discipline
matter that the employee has the right
to have that in public session or
non-public session but even if it's a
non-public session you're opening a
public meeting which would mean that
if your board's only meeting for that
employee matter you're opening the
public meeting the public would have a
right to come and talk about whatever
they wanted to
so you know we certainly uh you know
agree that that that the public comment
is is appropriate for school boards for
every
public body every water commission every
library trustees meeting
um
uh we think that would would be
imprudent um and just it's important to
note too um
i'd be remiss if i didn't state that the
state board of education has not taken
public comments in about a year
um we asked them to be
sort of set the example for our local
school board so
um you know
obviously the bill would require them if
to do that if it were to to go through
but i just want to put it out there that
the state board of education has not
taken public comments um in about a year
so we're in opposition to the bill i'm
happy to answer any questions that the
committee may have
representative nader thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question i'm a little bit confused
because the bill is about public comment
at the start of the school board how why
would that affect what we do here
so i'm reading on page line three of the
bill representative because all meetings
of a public body open to the public
under the chapter shall include a period
of public comment at the beginning of
the agenda for the meeting the bill is
not specific to school boards to build
specific to all public bodies under the
right to no law um the the the
introduction of the bill spoke
specifically to school boards but the
language of the bill applies it to all
public bodies and the definitions of
public bodies in the statute the general
court including executive sessions and
including any advisory committee
established by the general court the
executive council and the governor with
executive council so there'd have to be
a public comment period when governor
and council were meeting
any board or commission of any state
agency or authority i just said that the
state board of education is not taking
public comments currently
the board of trustees of the university
system of new hampshire and any
committee advisory or otherwise they're
established by such entities so i've
never been to a meeting of the board of
trustees i don't know if they take
public comment or not
any legislative body governing body
board commission committee agency or
authority of any county town municipal
corporation school district so all these
public bodies listed in this in the
definition of a public body under rsa 91
a1a
would be required to comply with this
provision because it's all meetings of a
public body shall have a public comment
period
are there other questions mr
christina guess i did have it
occurred to me one thing that we have
our town meetings
town meeting includes the first article
which is the election
of officers so
if i were to read this literally it
would appear that we need to have a
public comment period before we have our
election i
thank you i'm not sure if there was a
question in there um mr chair would you
believe the question i think
i think the
the the town meeting or the school
district annual meeting
it's kind of a public meeting it's kind
of not
you know for example um
public comment policies for a school
board can limit it to say residents of
the district
or perhaps or or not you know a school
board could not have a provision in
there limiting it to to residents of the
district we know that generally some
moderators have rules that if somebody
wishes to speak who is not a voter or
resident of that district they have to
get permission from the moderator so
there's some some nuances there
certainly open to the public anybody can
come in
and watch but you know sometimes if
there's non-voters they'll put them over
in sort of the the the roped off section
if you will
representative welper's sort of nodding
and smiling along with me so but but you
know yeah you would you may have to have
a public comment period at the beginning
of your annual meeting and the comments
may or may not be germane to the
business of the legislative body they
could talk about global warming as i
said global warming the war in
afghanistan
uh you know
the loch ness monster and who knows what
else thank you
any other questions
thank you to the committee
thank you for your testimony today thank
you
thank you mr chair nate graves for the
new hampshire municipal association i'm
going to answer your question to the
last witness in the affirmative yes that
is the interpretation we would have
is that any public any meeting of any
public body would have to have a
15-minute
public comment period
and as the last witness alluded to
we think this is uh broader than it
needs to be uh if this is something the
committee wants to do there are no
exceptions included in this bill
so you could have anything from a
cemetery trustees commission which
virtually never has anyone come before
it um have to have a 15 minute period
um
and
you know there's no reason for that to
occur
it's not clear that they could conduct
board business for that 15 minutes or
whether they just have to sit there and
twiddle their thumbs
you have town meeting which
is a meeting of a legislative body
it's the townspeople they're there to
vote whether or not they want
people who are
not members of that body to speak is
something the body gets to decide
and
they'd have to sit there and listen to
people talk for 15 minutes potentially
if a board is meeting just for a
non-public session is really the only
thing on the agenda so for example
select board might be considering
abatements
and all of the abatements are uh
are for people in town who simply can't
afford their property taxes
maybe they're you know on fixed incomes
disabled uh veterans et cetera
they're going to meet in non-public
session to discuss the abatements
you know they're not going to
that's going to be a reputation issue if
they put that out in public
um and
really all they're doing at that meeting
is discussing those finalizing that
nobody's going to
know what happens at the non-public
session except that it's you know they
probably won't figure out it's for
abatements but
um
there's really no reason to have a
public comment period to begin that and
the list kind of goes on and on and on
um
you know i don't think i will join the
last witness to open up the legislative
session here at the general court but
that's certainly a concern as well
i'm happy to take questions
questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much
and our last card is gloria atalani
i'll be quick
my name is lori ordolano i'm the vice
president of right to know new hampshire
we support this bill hb1195 relative to
amending public comment period
at a public meeting and we've amended
the language and
your copy reflects the amended language
we are supporting public comment
becoming a part of our open meetings we
support public comment at the beginning
and the end of the meeting the initial
comment would allow the public to
provide input on items being acted upon
additionally members of the public who
can't stay for the second period as
often meetings can run late they would
be assured of input the second public
comment period would allow comments for
future agenda items around motions made
during the meeting
i didn't bring you the attached nashua
public comment ordinance because
i had a printer issue late last night so
i'm going to send it in electronically
but in nashua we adopted a policy where
we allow a time limit of three minutes
with a total public comment time of 15
minutes for our public meetings this is
a written policy we adopted it from
manchester
just and even though that's our standing
written policy it doesn't mean every
meeting has a public input
if it's not a regular meeting of the
board if it's a special meeting that
they're holding
or a non-public meeting they don't put
one on
so the amended language we struck the
last few lines and we wrote the
individual public comment time shall be
not less than three minutes with a total
public comment time for each period of
not less than 15 minutes the content of
the public comment should not be limited
the statements made here with some
concern if you would have to hold 15
minutes of public comment if nobody was
there i don't see why that would be an
issue if nobody's there to give public
comment then there is no public comment
to accept and i don't i don't understand
that you would actually sit there
for 15 minutes you know the courts have
ruled in the past let's say non-public
session if you have meetings where
nobody is present and a board goes into
non-public session very often they're
not calling out the statutes to go into
non-public session
and the courts have ruled that they
didn't violate 91a because there was no
it's sort of like when a tree falls if
no one's there to hear it did it make a
sound you know if nobody's there to hear
it called out they don't necessarily
call it out
and
the courts have ruled that that's been
implied it was implied that that was a
private meeting and these are boards
that are operating with no public coming
into attendance
so
um
and i can see the need for amending the
language somewhat if we need to call out
that there are certain special meetings
that wouldn't have public comment but
for the most part many of our meetings
are regular monthly to the tune of 20 to
25 meetings for an elected body that are
agenda meetings with motions and actions
to be taken by the board and those are
the meetings that the public is looking
for public comment on
i can tell you one of the frustrations
that i see is that
public comment in the general meetings
is a policy um
is part of policy in nashua but what
happens is some of the general meetings
the agendas come out and there is no
public comment and that's where you run
into problems
you know when they don't follow policy
or they do it inconsistently
some towns
allow public comment they allow two the
second one is question and answer
they're just flexible about that so
that's great
but what happens is when you have an
important topic
that there's tremendous public input or
disagreement on controversy and you come
to a meeting and all of a sudden there's
no public comment
and you don't expect that that's when
you see your public get annoyed
and
um that's what's happening it's
interesting because i had a board of
health meeting in nashua yesterday at
noon and i raced down from here to go to
it to see what was going on the agenda
had no public comment they're supposed
to have public comment and they invited
in two hospital executives
to give essentially public comment
stating that it was they were invited
because of the interest of the public
and questions they had
but there was no
ability to ask any questions or to even
put a statement on the record
and no one knew those executives were
coming
and that's when the public becomes
frustrated
and i see this happening over and over
again on
you know issues of controversy and lord
knows the last two years have been
years that have been really challenging
for all of us
um and the school side is
really torn up and the municipal side
has its you know areas hot spots too
so
you're seeing you know we back this and
maybe to some extent it's a little
unusual but
we're seeing a lot of interest in
particularly on the school sides
and trying to get a public voice
established more regularly in these
meetings
so any questions and i i think i would
go back to my group and ask if we want
to consider amending it
to
make it clearer that we're looking at
the regular meetings of the board with
agendas and motions and action items not
special meetings of boards and to those
boards that never have the public come
put the public comment period in what do
you lose it's a it's a looks great on
your agenda
somebody might want to come
but a lot of them nobody comes so
it's a good will gesture and you're not
if i do the only question the the
sponsor
uh one of the co-sponsors representative
baldassaro when he testified he talked
about specifically about school board
meetings
really didn't
relate it to other types of meetings and
frankly in terms of the feedback i've
gotten
publicly from my district
i think the only criticism i've heard is
of regarding school boards in particular
and i was just wondering if you had
thoughts about
limiting the
this bill to
school board meetings as opposed to
making it across the board to every type
of public meeting
if that presents a
stopping point for it i'd like to see it
there for school boards really would i
but i think all groups like i said
boards of health are doing some
interesting things right now that have
interest in nashua
our assessing board has been doing some
interesting things that sometimes the
we'd like to
i can see it working on the municipal
side as well but certainly
i would be receptive and talk to right
to know new hampshire about just putting
this down for school boards
it's a starting point
i think it's very important
thank you
thank you very much
is there anyone else who would like to
seeing no one will close the hearing
on house bill 1195
i just like to thank those committee
members who hung in here all day i know
it was a very long day for everybody
and
the committee will be in recess until
nine o'clock next wednesday morning
you